thank you
Justin it is nice to see you very nice
to see you again yeah Tim great to see
you again as well and you are at maybe
undisclosed or you could disclose but
you are overseas at the moment so we are
across the pond or many ponds as it were
I'm glad we were able to make the timing
work and I thought we could begin with
magic so magic magic the Gathering is
is a game that I never really became
familiar with because I was older guard
at that point Dungeons and Dragons a lot
of the very first editions but my
younger brother on the other hand really
became immersed in Magic and actually
competed on some level and his friends
were just obsessed with magic the
Gathering so could you please for people
who don't have the context
explain what magic is and I suppose how
you became involved and what that
trajectory looked like
Magic's a trading card game invented by
Richard Garfield and so the what Trading
Card Game means is that you can buy it
not just like a normal game like
Monopoly you'd buy in a store it'd be a
single box here you buy packs of cards
like you would baseball cards and each
one has different gameplay elements and
the way I like to describe it for people
who don't know is it's sort of like a
cross between chess and poker where you
get to decide what deck of cards you're
going to play and what pieces you get to
play with right so there's the poker
element of I'm drawing a hand of cards
and maybe I can Bluff what I have and
you don't know and there's the chest
element of theirs tactically once I play
those cards there's tactically ways I
use them that kind of battle back and
forth so that's kind of a and then of
course it has fantasy characters and so
it appeals to people who like Dungeons
and Dragons so you'll be playing Wizards
and dragons and warriors and stuff like
that and so I first got involved with
magic in a pretty funny way actually so
I used to be on a competitive laser tag
league
so I have a very very competitive person
by Nature I've been involved in pretty
much whatever I do I'll find some way to
compete with it and in between games of
laser tag people were playing this card
game that looked really cool I'd never
heard of before and I watched them play
and I was like okay what is that so okay
so I go to the store and I just buy a
pack of cards and as I mentioned the
cards are totally random so I just took
all the random cards I bought and just
went to go play and I got my butt kicked
and it was of course okay you actually
have to construct and build your deck
and build your strategy and that helps
it you know come live so I came back the
next week and okay now I I played a
little better and a little better and
eventually at one point
all the guys from my group were all
going to go to a state championship
tournament so I lived in Miami at the
time and how old were you at this point
I was 16 years old okay got it so I was
a young kid so I was like oh hey come
along right come on the car ride and you
know those are some of my my best
memories in general just like you know a
bunch of guys hanging out jumping in the
car just talking about games riding up
and as it turns out I won that
tournament and so I ended up becoming
the state champion and that got me an
invitation to the national championships
and again I was not ever taking this
sort of seriously I wasn't even
intending to go in fact I was supposed
to go to debate camp that summer yet
another thing I was arbitrarily
competitive in and it ended up being my
my parents couldn't afford to send me
that year to debate Camp so last minute
I again my friends were all super
supportive here I ran a tournament at my
local game store they let me run the
event I collected the entry fees from
that tournament I used that to pay for a
plane ticket to fly to Columbus where
the U.S national championships was
happening I slept on a friend's floor
and I was now 17 at this time and I
ended up winning the US national
championships and that ends up taking me
on a career of traveling around the
world playing Magic for a living all
right so let's dive into a bunch of
things that you mentioned
and I was not aware of the debate Camp
component the debating piece I have
watched debates I've never been part of
a debate team could you just explain for
folks what a debate competition looks
like or a a debate as a game per se what
does that look like and why were you
good or at least competent at it there's
a few different categories there's
my favorite I'll just talk about my
favorite one which was it was called
Lincoln Douglas debate at the time and
it basically means that you have a topic
that you're debating like say you know
the US should have closer relationships
with China or it's better to sacrifice
the good of the a few for the good of
the many or something like that some
topic and then you would have to pick
one side of the argument and there's a
judge in the room and you have a certain
amount of time to make your case then
the other person a certain amount of
time to make their case and then you
have some time for rebuttal and they
have some time for rebuttal and at the
end the judge or judges would then
decide who who won
so that's kind of the outline of it and
there's a coin toss to decide who goes
first because that seems like a major
advantage all right so there's that well
it varies from round to round you'll go
first or second and this was sort of how
we did it in high school my favorite
version of debate was what I did in
college which was called parliamentary
debate where you could literally make up
any topic you wanted and just start
talking about it and the other side
would have to defend the other side and
you would just play and have fun and try
to figure out and convince people that
this was the way to go and it was just
it was such a fun exercise and just
persuasion and kind of tactically how
you wanted to frame everything and it
became yeah something I really spent
quite a bit of time on and really
enjoyed and it ended up being very
useful for quite a few things later in
life too it turns out being able to
speak good has value
so if we if we look at say the Lincoln
Douglas format
or the Parliamentary
I suppose the the formers may be a
better example to use here knowing
nothing about it but how much time do
you have to prepare once you are
assigned or have chosen one side of
let's just say the U.S should have
closer ties with China and you're either
Pro or con how much time do you have to
prepare that
and are you just basically making it up
but you're using the strength of your
logic that you construct even if your
assumptions are off to defeat your
opponent how does that work so for those
formats you have a the same topic will
hold for a while for like months like a
season and so you can prepare very much
ahead of time I see then there's other
ones like the Parliamentary one where
you have no idea what you're going to
talk about until you start going up
there a lot of the times and so that
that was more fun because it was a
little bit more extemporaneous so
there's varying degrees and so when you
have the same topic over and over again
you'd start to notice common threads
about how people will you know present
it and then some people would you know
you could try crazy things so maybe that
the US should have closer ties with
China and you would take a position
actually the U.S should not exist
anymore it should dissolve and you if
you start making arguments around that
and you just kind of have to take the
argument seriously in a sense because
it's the job of the judge is to sort of
leave outside their preconceived notions
and just hear what you have to say and
so having to think on your feet and
react and be able to kind of come up
with unique answers and change the flow
of things was really quite a bit of fun
I will move on to everybody listening I
will move on in a moment but I really
want to understand this because I
suspect as you mentioned that these are
threads that tie into other things later
at least some of them like these are not
isolated skills and if you're practicing
say the Parliamentary style and you are
developing this approach to structured
thinking and presenting
and you don't know what you're going to
be speaking about until you really sort
of get on the stage and somebody hands
you the mic it's like a sort of
freestyle rap battle when you get up
and then you give your Spiel how do the
judges
judge what does that look like yeah
great question because presumably they
might not know anything about the topic
that you're discussing so they can't
really fact check a lot of what you're
saying I would assume yeah that's right
there's no live fact checking in these
formats so you kind of just have to it's
about your persuasive ability so if I
were going to break this down into kind
of core skill sets and what the judges
are doing which is also what I'm doing
as a competitors anytime my opponent is
saying something right I'm writing down
their points right so I'm breaking them
down into kind of concrete notes and I
want to make sure that for each point
that's brought up I am addressing it in
some key way and now a lot of times I
can make some broader point that will
maybe take out a few of their points and
because you only have a certain amount
of time how efficiently you're able to
use that time to both refute the points
that they're saying as well as bring up
your own points that are hopefully
harder to refute so it becomes a kind of
process of being very good at listening
and taking notes then being able to
structure how do you want to set up your
replies so that they're you're gaining
time Advantage if you will with your
persuasive ability to give you more time
to make your own row of arguments so
that hopefully they don't have time in
their thing to properly address and
attack everything
mm-hmm okay great so as promised I'm
gonna move move forward this is great
I've never been asked about this before
so this is fun yeah yeah well that's I'm
trying to try to do my job it's as best
I can and returning to Magic so you
mentioned that led to all these
Adventures traveling around the world
competing
what does that mean could you explain
what
that looks like in terms of incentives
Stakes
how how profitable is it for someone to
be a full-time magic player I imagine it
depends on the person but
what does it mean to travel around the
world and compete
we're taking this back now date myself a
little bit but this is 97 when I won the
US national championships and my the
core of my career was about the six
years from 97 to about 2003. and that
time there was what was called The Magic
Pro Tour which was put on by the company
that made the game as a way to promote
it and they would have millions of
dollars of prizes available so at any
given tournament you could win so my
biggest tournament winnings would
typically be in the 30 000 range so a
pro tour in Houston where I won that or
you know these different tournaments so
to give you a sense you know first place
in one of those tournaments was thirty
thousand dollars ish all the way down
till you know top 32 maybe you'd get a
thousand dollars and you'd have to get
invited to these tournaments there'd be
maybe 300 people-ish that would get
invited and so I would do a tournament
in Prague then there'd be another one in
Sydney then there'd be another one in
Seattle there'd be another one you know
in Tokyo and so it got to literally just
meet up and again I'm I'm in high school
I'm a teenager right so this is just
like crazy for me it's a lot of money oh
my God it's crazy money right so I was
just like such a fun thing
but you know when you think about it as
a as an adult it wasn't you know it's
not a crazy crazy amount of money but it
was great at the time you can't win
every tournament but you know when I was
playing at my Peak I was maybe
eighty thousand dollars a year I was
making right so it's still not that's no
joke no joke at that time it was great I
mean it's how I paid my way through
college right so it was like a very you
know better than flipping burgers I'll
put it that way
what was your major in college I was a
philosophy major
how did you choose philosophy well as
you might guess I love debating
I mean I've always been very interested
in just sort of talking about the Deep
questions right trying to get down to
the fundamentals of what is interesting
and what matters and I tried a few
different
Majors you know history and
I was on my path to be a lawyer because
my parents are lawyers and that's what I
thought I was supposed to do but I found
most classes when I went to them the job
as a student in the class was to
regurgitate whatever it was that the
professor told you back to them and that
bored the hell out of me whereas in
philosophy the job was to make a
reasonable argument didn't matter just
like in debate right it was didn't
matter what your position was is can you
defend it do you have good Logic for it
and to try to like I loved being proven
wrong this was a kind of strength and a
weakness I loved debating with people
and I loved it when someone told me
something I didn't know or convinced me
I was wrong I was like that's amazing
that's great it took me a very long time
to realize most people are not like that
in high school I was voted most likely
to disagree with anything you say
so I learned to be a little bit more
cautious and compassionate in my
conversations with people but I I really
enjoyed it so philosophy let me explore
that space of really you know what
matters in the world and what matters to
me and really refined my thinking and
get challenged on my thinking when I was
unclear or fuzzy mm-hmm
I want to mention for people who may not
notice this pattern that on this podcast
there is disproportionate representation
of former philosophy majors
however that could be severe
survivorship bias right I guess I'm sure
there are many many philosophy Majors
who do not end up on large podcasts
however it is notable to me right you
have people who are deeply interested in
philosophy who also
end up in these conversations with me
Reid Hoffman would be another example
who I'm not sure if you majored in
philosophy but he has taught philosophy
and takes it very very seriously
why were you comfortable and maybe even
invigorated by being proven wrong or
converted in that way did that come from
being raised in a family of lawyers did
it come from something else what what
contributed to that yes I think there's
two factors here I think one you're
absolutely right my parents were were
wonderful in the sense that as as a kid
I could argue my way to a later bedtime
or I could argue my way to hey if I
finish my homework I can get an extra
setting of dessert or whatever they they
encouraged if I could kind of debate my
way to something then I could get it and
so it trained me very young and
similarly you know my dad and I we would
be play Cutthroat Cutthroat games of
Monopoly around the kitchen table quite
a bit but they did they reinforced that
after the game you know you you learn
like what did you learn if you lost what
did you learn from it and that's the
biggest thing that I credit for my
certainly my success in Magic and I've
tried to apply that everywhere else in
my life is that when you lose which you
inevitably are going to lose in life
right it doesn't matter what it is that
you look first like okay what could I
have done differently how could I have
set this up differently so that I
wouldn't even be in this position right
it's easy when you're playing a game
like magic where some your opponent
draws a lucky card you know it's a one
out of 60 that they draw that card and
they beat you because of it and you'd
hear in the hallways other people would
be complaining about what's called bad
beats right I got unlucky oh my God but
the best players wouldn't do that the
best players would say actually you know
what if five turns earlier I had made
this different play it wouldn't have
mattered what card They drew at that
time right and that skill set was
something that was drilled into me and
it's something I definitely credit quite
a bit of success across a variety of
fields
this might seem like a strange question
but
do magic competitors or did they
study games in the way that chess
players study historic games of Chess
where those moves and decisions are
recorded in some way I'm not sure if it
lends itself to that oh it absolutely
does and people would break these things
down so again let's we're going to take
ourselves in the Wayback machine right
97 98 this era the internet is still
relatively new right still relatively
light and so people know to what with
the times called the magic Dojo which
you can now find like the internet
archives and it was where everybody
would post tournament reports of okay
here's what I played here's what
happened and people would comment on
them and break down on you know kind of
more classic bulletin board style and
that's where the core of magic strategy
and discussion started to form and now
there's dozens of sites and dozens of
places where you can find this but it
was a you know unlike with chess where
people been doing this strategy and
breaking down games for hundreds of
years right Magic's 30 years old or
whatever and at the time it was very new
and so you I got to see the origins of
these strategies come together and you
know break down individual games and
individual moves and they became
obsessive I mean if if you look at my
old College notebooks they are covered
in Magic deck ideas and scribbles and
like at least as much as there are notes
about philosophy or whatever it was I
was supposed to be studying
what were the main Innovations if you
had to try to
Identify some game design elements that
led to or contributed to Magic becoming
such a global phenomenon
what would you say were the Innovations
I mean there's definitely the slot
machine like
dopamine potential of buying these packs
just like buying baseball cards right
but
what else is there in the game
that made it at least have the
possibility of exploding the way that it
did
there's a lot of factors there's kind of
a deep answer but we have a long-form
podcast so if you don't mind we love
these answers yeah take all the time you
want so I teach game design and when
there's sort of five major categories of
like what people are looking for out of
games and
magic hits all of them in ways so I'll
talk about the categories first and then
I'll talk about why magic succeeds in
such an incredible way so the first is
immersion right you're looking for
certain experiences or you're looking to
tell craft a story right the second is
connection you're looking to socialize
you want to help other people you want
to kind of connect with others the third
is aspiration right this can be in
competition this can be like
achievements you want to win you want to
prove you're better than
prove you can achieve something
then the fourth is growth right you want
to learn you want to continue to kind of
move up
and improve your skills and the last is
expression right this idea that you want
to customize or role playing works this
way because we express different parts
of ourselves through role-playing and so
those are the kind of the major
categories
and I think magic allowed people to
both not only have these competitions
like I was doing but it allowed people
to customize and grow in a world where
it's infinitely deep right at a certain
point with chess it's a deep game but
there's only so many pieces I can learn
them all I can just I can know kind of
the frame I'm playing it with magic
there's constantly new cards coming
there's constantly new things to do and
I get to own I get to customize and own
my experience so to relate it to
something like you've more familiar with
right Dungeons and Dragons right the
idea that you get to tell the story that
you get to create the character is so
powerful and so immersive and Magic is
very similar if you want to build a deck
with all
elf cards you could do that if you want
to build a deck that has every card that
you could imagine and it is 300 cards
deck you know cards you can do that
right if you want to be the hyper
competitive hyper Focus guy you could do
that right there are so many experiences
that you get to in a sense design your
own game and it's one of the things that
I've learned you know much like you
talked about a lot of philosophy Majors
end up on your podcast a lot of the game
designers
started from a game like magic or
Dungeons and Dragons and because as you
play You're crafting your own experience
and I think that was such a unique and
powerful thing and and Dungeons and
Dragons could be a little intimidating
for people because it's so open it's so
intimidating it's so complex or at least
it can be yeah it can be exactly whereas
magic like you're playing inside of
these box and these rules but once you
start exploring it then this whole world
opens up and I think that was really the
magic of it so quote unquote and it
really made it feel like something that
was very new and spawned an entire genre
of games
I remember one point I think it was
it's certainly at the time I think TSR I
was reading
this book called I believe it's art and
Arcana or Arcana I'm not sure how you
pronounced that word properly even
though I've read it a thousand times
which is a
Visual History of Dungeons and Dragons
and at some point they realized one of
the major stumbling blocks was people
having to develop from scratch their own
characters and they provided out of the
box templates which was one of the ways
they
jump started wider adoption it's giving
people an easy place to start with some
type of
positive constraints let's just say in a
sense and that makes me think about
magic now can you remind me and
listeners of who developed Magic
Richard Garfield was the lead designer
he created the game along with of course
a lot of other people that supported but
he was the lead the Creator I remember
listening to and you're going to have to
fact check me on this but I think I
think I'm recalling this correctly
listening to at least one maybe two
interviews with Richard on your podcast
think like game designer and
he was talking about game development
and I guess folks who are auditing the
cards and the decks and the idea that
some cards would get retired or removed
from circulation or banned because they
were too powerful but if there were no
cards that were too powerful
that they were also airing on the side
of caution something along those lines
could you expand on what I'm very
clumsily trying to recall from an
interview I listened to a year ago so
there's this idea in games of balance
which is a very it's a term that people
throw around a lot but gets very
confused and the principle of it is that
you don't want some part of your game to
be so unfair that you can't nobody can
beat you right so if it's you know if
it's uh in tic-tac-toe if you get to
make three moves at once that would be
pretty unfair right the game is already
over you've got your three in a row that
doesn't make any sense so the game's no
fun so the idea is you want to make sure
that there's no one strategy that's too
good but some people think that that
means everything needs to be exactly the
same and that's also not true because
the idea if every card is just as
equally good as every other card then
you deny people that Discovery you deny
people that ability to learn and say oh
okay hold on like as a new player you
don't know anything and then you can
learn oh actually you know what this
card's better than this card or the
excitement of chasing and finding
something that's very exciting that now
you can combine with something else that
you have and suddenly that gets better
and so the way I Define balance is not
everything has to be equal it's that
there's no one strategy that should be
unbeatable right that if you know the
best analogy is if you think like rock
paper scissors perfectly balanced game
right rock is great but if I know you're
gonna throw a rock I've got a plan I
could throw paper and I'm gonna be okay
right and so there's there's a lot of
ways that you can approach balance but
that can give you a sense of like what
it should look like and so for Richard
he wanted to make things that were
exciting and Chase and you know you're
really hoping you open up in a pack
of course he didn't have any idea that
the game was going to be as popular as
it was when he talked about in the
podcast episode that you know he thought
you would just never even see all the
cards that some people would have a
couple packs and other people would have
a couple packs and you just Discover it
as you went and that is actually it's an
exciting prospect but very quickly
people would buy all the cards and now
there's spoilers on the internet and
everybody sees everything immediately
and so it's it's changed a lot since his
initial concept
all right so as the next lily pad
I want to explore one of two things
we're going to get to both so you can
choose which you think makes sense to
talk about first so
the first option is your your path to
where you are now as a senior partner at
a law firm just kidding so the so law
school yeah the other is
what happened in your magic life
after winning the Nationals and that
story so which which of those do you
think makes sense to tackle first well I
think or you can talk about both in
tandem either one yeah yeah we'll go and
kind of chronology order so that the
magic career kind of has its Arc before
my my law career has its much shorter
Arc so I'm 17 years old I win the US
national championships this was like a
huge awesome cool thing for me
but then I go to the World Championships
and at that point in Magic's life cycle
the US was dominant the US had never
lost a World Championships ever
and I was not just me but a team of
people that were representing the US and
unfortunately we did not win but we did
not do very well and so that World
Championships I was then had this
albatross around my neck of being the
first loser U.S national champion at
least the story I was telling myself so
I was like okay this is not great and I
you know my career was good I was doing
good but it was something that always
stuck with me and so I kept wanting to
try to get back on the national team to
like redeem myself
so fast forward five years later
finally the U.S loses again loses to the
Germans so as now I'm not the only loser
not that I was rooting against the us
but it was nice to not be the only loser
and then the very next year I make it
back on the U.S national team and so
this is my chance like my chance at
Redemption after six years and I've with
two other people on the team and the two
people that are on the team with me they
were like pretty new to the game they
were you know kind of come out of
nowhere just like I did when I first
started and I was so committed to making
sure we did well I paid to fly both of
them to Boston where I was living at the
time to like stay at my place and work
and we trained for like month month and
a half together with my team who was uh
Your Move games was the local store and
group we would play test with so I could
we trained we slept on my couch we
worked together to be able to make it
back to that year the World
Championships were in Berlin so we're
going into enemy territory and
and it comes down to literally we make
it to the final table to the final game
it comes down to me playing this match
and you know this is we've got stage
lights we're covering it this is like
everything I have worked for and there's
some online records of the experience
but I am like I remember just sort of
feeling in that moment that you know
I've been in tournaments I'd won
tournaments I lost tournaments there's a
certain amount of excitement and
pressure but for this one it was so much
of a personal story a personal kind of
drama that I was playing out for me and
I drew my hand the first time for this
final match where everything's on the
line people are watching and there's a
rule in Magic where if you don't like
your hand if you don't like the starting
cards you have you can take a mulligan
and what that means is you you throw the
cards away but you get one less card and
it's a big deal like less cards is a
huge disadvantage in the game but I draw
my hand and I'm trying to make this like
this decision and I'm just like all
right do I deal with what I have or do I
just take a shot and
I didn't like the hand I wasn't gonna
let the World Championships be decided
on that hand so I'm Mulligan throw the
cards away my teammates are groaning in
the background
yeah it's like all right here we go
Shuffle Up draw the hand and and it
becomes one of those moments where you
kind of like see it come together like
the hand was good enough we start
playing it out
I get some board advantage
my opponent's kind of on his back foot
and he's got a couple tricks there's
some cards I have to play around I'm not
really sure and then finally I'm able to
kind of get to the point
and win this fight after however long
people Rush the stage like able to
finally like take that off of my back
and it was a very exciting moment for me
it was a very fun journey and it was a
result of a lot of hard work right it
was like a lot of dedication that got
there but it kind of felt for me that
was like it was like the end of my magic
career it was like the thing that had
like I had been striving to do that I
kind of like checked those boxes and
that was kind of like what let me move
to this next stage
so before we get to
your short Arc in the world of law
was there something coming back to your
previous comment that you learned after
losing on the world championship stage
first was there something you learned or
decided to change about your approach
after that
now we're talking about years of Gap in
between right and so what I what I did
learn and the major thing that I I
realized in that like magic is generally
a single person game right I'm playing a
match against somebody else in
competition but in this case it's a team
game and I think the biggest shift in
Focus was I didn't just think about
myself like I had to think about how do
I lift everybody else up and all Thrive
together to be able to make it through
and it really
it changed the way I focused there
changed the way I focused with other
teams I've worked with it made a huge
impact and then just being willing to
again come back from a loss and not let
it discourage you that you can't
overcome it but I think that that being
able to work typically most of the games
I've played have been single player you
know whether it was debate or wrestling
or most of magic like it was all about
like I'm here to win and I think my
shift in mindset was no I'm here for us
to win and you know that was a really
huge turnaround for me yeah that's a big
shift in terms of looking through the
prism so Law School
tell us about Law School
so just to frame this right so I've
already mentioned both my parents are
lawyers my mom's lawyer my dad's a
lawyer my stepdad's a lawyer I was you
know debate Captain I was doing I was
supposed to be a lawyer that was just
like my path from as early as I can
remember that's what I was supposed to
do and even though I had been making a
living and traveling around the world
playing Magic at no point did it ever
occur to me that that I would make a
living in games not it was just oh this
is a fun thing to do while I'm in
college it was just not in my I had this
mental block
and so you know graduate go get into
NYU Law I
teach the LSAT for a while I go to law
school and I'm lucky I'm a pretty happy
guy by default but this was the first
time I was really depressed like I was
very unhappy for an extended period of
time and I I will remember very
specifically there's one day I'm getting
up I'm living in Brooklyn
snowing outside just like covered in you
know ice in the floor and I have to get
trudged up put on all of these
ridiculous clothes and go to get on the
A train and pretend like I'm not staring
at anybody else and everybody has to
studiously avoid looking at anybody else
in New York that's just the rule and
make it all the way in have my Boston
cream Donut for breakfast because that's
just how I lived back then and I I go
into this NYU Law Library which is like
you know you can picture this just
cavernous giant library with old oak and
towers of books it was back when you had
to use books to learn things it was a
wild time
and I checked out the blah books I had
to read before class and I'm
you know stack them up these just towers
around me and I'm just there and I'm
there for hours just like reading case
law and just not very happy but um a
couple hours later I realized I got to
get to class and so I sit up
and I have this jolt of pain through my
spine like jewels of pain I can't I can
barely move I'm hobbling to get out of
there and I realize I threw my back out
from reading from reading that is how
unhealthy I was I was about 40 pounds
heavier than I am now how just like
miserable I was and I like this was my
first clue that I'm on the wrong path
right and I think this is something I
just it's a really important lesson I
think for every I imagine there's a lot
of overachievers in your audience and
that this path of trying to win whatever
games in front of you it can be way
worse to win the wrong game than even to
lose one that you actually enjoy playing
and that was a big shift for me and
fortunately that summer I had an
opportunity to go instead of interning
at a law firm I got to go do a work on a
Marvel Comics card game a Marvel vs DC
Comics card game for a company called
Upper Deck in San Diego so summer
internship working on comic book games
instead of that sounded great and so I
flew across country to go and work there
for the summer and again even though I
knew I was miserable even though I'd had
this terrible experience even though I
now had a kind of opportunity in front
of me it's still my assumption at this
point was I'm gonna go back to law
school I'm gonna go back and that's just
I gotta finish that path but I come out
to start working on games and I am in
love with it I'm super passionate about
it I'm enjoying it again we're debating
these really interesting ideas about
design and definitely happy to dig into
what that looks like
but then when they offer me a full-time
job
I'm still stressing about this you know
and it's still finally when I make the
decision I tell my mom she she literally
cries when I tell her I'm leaving law
school to go become a game designer
right like it was so hard and I look
back and it's so silly to me this is one
of the things you've you know taught me
I didn't have these words at the time
but I learned it through like this idea
of like fear setting where in fact I
wasn't really giving up anything right I
could always go back to law school but
it just didn't feel like that at the
time and so being able to break out of
that spell and then go follow a path
that was really passionate for me that I
was really excited about one of the best
decisions I ever made how did you find
the internship
so this was fortunate because of my
magic career they had reached out to me
to kind of just like vet their game and
you know check it out and stuff so some
of the other people on the Magic Pro
Tour people who I'd known had already
kind of been hired there so they were
like hey and they knew I was miserable I
you know would chat with them they're
like hey come out for the summer come
work on this thing you got nothing to
lose kind of deal
has your mom come around or is she still
hoping for that day when you return to
law school now my mom has come around
I'm sure she'll listen to this episode
hi Mom she did and this is the thing the
people in our lives there's a lot of
pressure that we all feel right whether
it's from parents from friends from like
they want the best for us right she just
wants me to be happy and safe and
comfortable and it just you know you've
got to realize that you in order to find
the path that you actually want for
yourself the path that you will be
fulfilled by you gotta be uncomfortable
you got to be unsafe right parents I
think try to protect their kids so much
in reality you can't you've got to be
able to like push past that and and she
knows that now and she was very happy it
all worked out yeah all right well we're
gonna film the gaps for those people who
aren't your mom listening hi Mom uh
since we have a lot to fill in and look
now I feel like I should defend your mom
also certain paths are more predictable
than others and there is the perception
and maybe even the reality of safety
consistency stability with certain
choices but as you said
choosing the right game is more
important than winning the game that
just happens to be in front of you yeah
and at least in certainly in my
experience and the experience of a lot
of people on this podcast and just
because something is unpredictable does
not automatically make it unsafe it just
makes it less certain and as you put it
many of these things for instance I'll
give you another example and this is
very analogous when people invoke the
names of say Zuckerberg or someone else
who dropped out
as this throwing caution to the wind
burning the boats behind them to take
the risk of Entrepreneurship
whenever possible I try to point out
that's actually not the case for most
people who say take a leave of absence
from a Harvard or Stanford they can go
back anytime they want to go back 100
and again you've said this better than
honestly anybody like this idea that
most of the fears that we have this
resistance to uncertainty is just made
up in our head right there's so many
ways you can recover and go back and if
you can just remember that right I could
have gone back to law school later on
when I quit my game design job to start
a company I could always get another job
like those things are those illusions of
uncertainty and fear if you can push
past that it changes everything I mean
most of the times we take risks we're
not jumping off cliffs or you know into
burning buildings it's just okay yeah
your career takes a different path or
you have to you're you're behind in
school or whatever it's it's a very low
cost yeah most often recoverable so I
will I'll link to fear setting and
people can just search fear setting like
goal setting with a hyphen in it and all
sorts of things will pop up if you just
search that or go to tim.blog Ted
because that was the topic of of my TED
Talk I suppose quite a few years ago now
but
moving on from
fear setting for a moment it might it
might come back into the conversation
who knows but what did that first year
or six months month could be the first
week however you want to frame it of
designing games look like what was that
experience like
it's a really fun question because
people just make this assumption that
because like I was good at playing games
then that means I would be good at
making games and they are 100 different
skills like I did not think of myself as
a creative person like I there was I
thought there was just some kind of like
magic special secret sauce that other
people had and I was just gonna I was
just gonna fake it and go out there and
see what happened and so when I go there
I'm having serious imposter syndrome
right I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know how to make this come to life
and I researched a ton I you know I read
some some great books on creativity a
whack on the side of the head as one I'd
recommend
and I started to talk to other people
who I did respect as designers and kind
of break it down and over time I I
realized that there is no there's
nothing that differentiates like a
creative person from a not creative
person other than process and so as an
analytically minded person I was able to
break it down into what I what I call
the core design Loop which is a six step
process of how do you create not just
games but I think every creative field
it applies to
and so learning that and I was very
lucky I'll talk about the details of it
I won't leave you hanging on that piece
but I won't let you leave me hanging
just to immerse the experience of it
right I was lucky in a sense and that
you know I went to go work at a company
where I had a lot of friends that were
already there and I had immediate
deadlines right like this game is going
to release you have to turn over the
file with the cards and the things like
within two months and so there was no
choice but to act right so what I say
it's the deadlines are magic like it
doesn't matter if you have no idea what
you're doing you have a deadline
literally going to just say the exact
same thing verbatim it's like what a
beautiful constraint it's just
remarkable what you get done yeah so
that was I think a real powerful tool
about why like so one really short
deadlines and my job was on the line so
I had Stakes right and I didn't want to
go back to law school
and two that I had other people that I
could like ask and talk to who were
smarter than I was who had done it
before and I could get some insight into
right so so being able to kind of find
you know either books or mentors or
other people that you can you can talk
to was also helped accelerate it so that
eventually turned into this kind of
step-by-step process so if you'd like I
I can go into that now or I can jump
into other stuff actually before we get
into the process
could you
explain why a whack on the side of the
head was impactful for you or what you
took from that that was valuable because
in the course of doing homework for this
conversation I I noticed that you had
mentioned this book before and I
actually have a deck of cards designed
by the same author yes I have not read
the book however could you speak to why
that had an impact or why you recommend
it
so it's nice in that it helps to
in a sense demystify creativity and and
just bring it down to like a very kind
of simple granular level and I'll give
it some examples so
one of the principles in it is that I've
used all the time is basically
and I forget how they were in the book
but basically like turn the object
around in your mind right if you take
something that you normally think of one
way how many different ways can you look
at that same thing right so if you have
a pen right you can say all right well
what do you do with a pen well you can
write with it okay well no all right I
could use it to help force me to Smile
by biting it I could use it to prop up
my microphone I could use it right you
could trying exercises that give you
different frames were very powerful and
ways to like break you out of your
thinking
the idea of using random constraints so
one of the exercises that's I encourage
anybody to do if they want to it's like
if you're having a problem some creative
challenge some block right go to a
random book on your shelf open it to a
random page and point to a random word
right some substitute word now figure
out how that word relates to whatever
your problem is and journal on that for
like five minutes ten minutes and you'll
be amazed at how all of a sudden it can
crack open something because we get so
linearly focused on the problem in front
of us and even a completely random
constraint can open up the door for you
and we'll give one more move past the
quote unquote right answer right that
you may have an answer and say okay
that's fine and you stop most people
stop instead say okay I'm going to look
for the third right answer the fourth
right answer the fifth right I'm going
to look beyond that to go deeper and
find more things so so just these little
exercises and you could just do those
exercises would suddenly say like oh wow
okay I'm already seeing myself be more
creative I'm already seeing myself do
more than I was and so that was a the
book was impactful because it could just
like by the time I was done reading it I
had already seen myself do creative
things I didn't think I could do in ways
that sound pretty stupid I'm sure me
saying it like pick a random page of the
book be more creative trust me try it
you know it works without having read
that book I have used this approach and
actually writing
teachers that I had long ago back when I
had hair and was in school
also would offer these types of random
constraints it's almost like the itching
approach to creativity right it's like
okay you just like throw a bunch of
Scrabble tiles on the floor and you pick
the three that are closest to you and
like that's your constraint or that's
the filter in a sense or what directs
the exercise very very powerful and I
wanted to mention since you were talking
about going past the right answer and
finding the third right answer actually
reminded me of
something a former guest Derek sivers
who's one of my favorite people he's
been on a few times and when I asked him
who he thought of when he heard the word
successful he said well my first answer
might be say Richard Branson but
that really ultimately depends on his
goals in life and if his goal was to
have a quiet Life undisturbed by
entrepreneurship then that wouldn't be
successful so let me skip the first
answer get to the second answer get to
the third answer and he said what you
should ask people is who is the third
person who comes to mind when you hear
the word successful and it's really a
powerful heuristic that you can use in
in all sorts of ways all right so that's
that's a snapshot on a whack on the side
of the head let's talk about the core
design Loop yeah before we jump into the
core design Loop I'm going to give one
more thing it's not from a whack on the
side of the head but it's something I've
actually developed more recently as a
process that I find super valuable and
yeah one of the things that we try to do
in our company is always surface our
assumptions right there's a lot of
things where you're assuming a game is
going to be fun because of this we
assume people are looking for that we
assume we're making this category of
game Etc and a really great exercise to
do that's in this spirit is once a
quarter we'll do an assumptions
challenging exercise
and what that means is you surface every
assumption you can everybody so if
you're not you can do this by yourself
or if you're on a team everybody writes
down on their own all their assumptions
you put them all up on a shared board or
a shared Google doc if you're doing
remote like we are and then you one by
one okay what if that weren't true or to
use your terminology what if I did the
opposite right and it's so powerful
because sometimes it doesn't mean
anything right sometimes it's like okay
that doesn't make any sense you move on
but without fail by the time we finish
that exercise we find some core
assumption that all of a sudden changes
everything and that ability to just take
what you assume to be true one making it
explicit in the first place is super
powerful just so you know really what
you're doing and then two is this this
inversion process is incredibly powerful
could you give any examples just to make
it a little Concrete in the minds of
folks listening yeah yeah of what those
assumptions might might be right so I
made this game called soulforge with
with Richard Garfield the guy that
created magic and we did this over a
decade ago and we made it as a digital
trading card game and so purely you play
it on your phone no physical objects at
all the game was successful we ran it
for a few years and eventually we we
took it down and we were talking about
we wanted to bring it back because we
loved the game we wanted to bring it
back and one of the exercises which is
okay so Forge is a digital game
and then we're like wait what if it's
not like what would that look like and
we had built it to be a digital game but
then all of a sudden we're like well now
it's seven years later digital printing
technology is way better than it was you
can actually algorithmically create
one-of-a-kind cards and create things
and that started us down this road of
investigating this new technology so the
new version of soulforge called sulfur
Fusion is now a physical card game that
has this new technology built into it
which never would have happened if we
had just gone with our assumptions of oh
okay we're going to remake the same game
again so that's like one example of this
is recently impactful for me in this
yeah I love that I can't tip my hand too
hard here publicly but I've been
very much focused on possibly working on
my first book in five or six years
it's been a long time I wasn't sure I
would do another one but I've been very
strongly considering it and
I've been not in written form which
would be more helpful I think but in a
sort of Meandering
mental form with which is sort of a mix
of like reverie skepticism and
daydreaming
looking at some of the basic assumptions
like is it a book right I think of it as
a book but does it even need to be a
book period or I should say a question
mark and if it is a book for instance
generally if you're
going through the publishing process or
you have been through the publishing
process you've been your thinking has
been shaped in in a certain way over and
over again you're like okay I have to do
print audio ebook
and you sell all of those to one person
well what if we split those up what if
there was no print whatsoever what would
that look like and just testing these
very basic assumptions right and I'll
give you one example also
which people might not realize or if
you're outside of publishing why would
you realize this but none of my books in
the US have ever gone to paperback
and if you were to ask most authors like
why have you gone to Paperback the
answer would generally be something
along the lines of well the Publishers
always do that a year and a half after
the hardcover they lower the price to
make the market
larger for the book and you come out in
paperback and I was like
but if you look at the math does that
make any sense for you and then they
think about it and they're like well let
me think about that okay I was making 15
on each hardcover book
which is already discounted on Amazon to
something very affordable
and now when I go to Paperback wait a
second my royalties just got cut to
seven and a half or six and a half now I
have to sell twice as many books to make
the same amount in royalties oh [__]
that makes no sense whatsoever it's also
not really relevant in a world where
ebook is an option
if that makes any sense if somebody is
looking for a lower price they can buy
it on ebooks so
hence from the beginning none of my
books have ever gone to paperback
okay so let's if you're open to it we
can we can certainly I mean I love as
you know you know this very well I love
digging into testing assumptions because
yeah those are the rules that that's
like the operating your assumptions of
the operating system that governs your
life in a way right that's right and you
want to make sure those rules can be
justified on some level
but maybe it makes sense to hop into the
core design Loop and talk about that a
bit yeah I think it's a perfect segue
because exactly what we're talking about
with assumptions is going to come into
play in the core design so the core
design Loop is how
games are made it's how creative
projects are done but we're going to
focus on games so that's the the kind of
main topic I teach at it so the
courtesan loop is six steps it's
inspiring framing brainstorming
prototyping testing and iterating
so Step One is inspiring what is it
that's driving you right what's the core
of what you're excited about so it could
be you want to make a game for this IP
this world that you love could be you
want to make a [__] punch game could we
want to make a game about fantasy
Warriors right hypothetically speaking
or Miniatures right if you love me
exactly yeah you love Miniatures you
know you want to make a miniature scheme
right it could be a component could be a
theme could be a mechanic could be you
want to make a game about dog walking
whatever it is right you're excited what
is at the heart of what you're doing
right and in general that heart is going
to be an experience you want to create
for your audience right but you start at
something whatever high level thing it
gets you excited then framing is a lot
we talked about right we want to put a
box around it we want to put constraints
around it and so that constraint should
always include a deadline ideally a
short deadline to whatever your next
step is so I'm gonna have a prototype to
test in two weeks it could be look one
one of the most common mistakes I see
game designers make they come to me okay
I want to make a game it's like Halo and
World of Warcraft and Grand Theft Auto
but like all rolled into one with like a
bunch of cool stuff happening right and
these are massive games that take
millions and millions of dollars and
teams of people it's like well you've
never made a game before maybe let's
start with like a simple card game right
so constraints with your components
constraints with time like what is the
what's the space I'm playing in
step three is brainstorming and
brainstorming is where you ideate and
come up with your ideas and I'm very
particular about how I recommend people
brainstorming this comes from research
from the Wharton School of Business and
work that I've done with them but the
basics are three phases and to get
really granular because I know that your
audience likes that I break it into
three steps 20 minutes each first is
where you're open exploring right you
write as many things as you can
as many ideas as you can and don't stop
so don't there's always this like critic
part of our brain that's like no that's
stupid no that won't work turn that off
just write down as many things as you
can if you're if your pen stops moving
for more than 10 seconds you're doing it
wrong right as many ideas you can on the
paper then
the second stage also recommend 20
minutes is organizing where you take
this massive ridiculous some cool ideas
some ridiculous ideas and you start to
try to find like patterns between them
and if you're trying to make something
specific you start to kind of think
through okay if I'm trying to make a
game what's the victory condition how do
people figure out what are their moves
how do they interact you know you start
trying to kind of put some structure
around it or if it's a book okay what's
the what's the opening of the book how
are people how's it going to help people
who's my audience whatever it is right
and then you as you start making these
connections you're naturally going to
see gaps and you're going to fill those
gaps in
and then the last step which is also 20
minutes is elimination and that's where
you you went from starting with as many
ideas as you can and now you want to get
to as few ideas as possible so that you
can start moving to testing them
and so that's where you go and you'll
try to like okay what's the minimum
amount that I can prototype which is the
next step to test my idea right to test
my assumption to test the core of what
I'm doing and so prototyping is exactly
what it sounds like you know talk about
an MVP this minimum viable product
what's the smallest thing I can do to
test my idea what's the easiest way I
can do this
and then step five is testing where you
actually show it to somebody you get
some feedback you actually figure out
what's going on there and then step six
is iterating where you take what you've
learned and then you cycle back through
the process and and what I've learned is
that the skill of creativity
specifically with game design but really
with anything is how well you can kind
of flow through that process
and get the most out of each Loop and go
through as many Loops as possible
all right we're going to come back to
brainstorming in a second but what I
want to do for people listening is
highlight
and you said this already but I want to
just make a few
notes and give a few examples this
process can apply to almost anything and
for instance
you want to start a podcast I'll use
I'll use that as an example right
inspiration thematically where are you
going what is the format that you're
excited about what is driving you to be
considering starting a podcast right
setting parameters thinking about the
constraints what are the constraints how
do you keep it
interesting enough that you continue to
do it but simple enough that you don't
quit after three episodes and the
example you gave was like I want it to
be like Halo Plus World of Warcraft plus
Warhammer and you're like whoa whoa whoa
whoa easy the reason there is an
elephant graveyard of a Million Dead
podcasts that stopped after episode
three is they're like I Love This
American Life and I think it's going to
be like this American life meets cereal
meets Joe Rogan and I'm like whoa slow
down taxi there's a reason the credits
are five minutes long at the End of This
American Life yeah I'm not sure you
realize how much goes into making that
and then brainstorming right coming up
with whether it's guests ideas for
questions Etc
prototyping right giving it a go maybe
you record as I did five or six episodes
before publishing your first so you have
a chance to kick the tires and try to
figure out what's working the testing
you're going to get in this case right
testing with your guests but also with
test listeners let's just say and then
iterating this also applies to books
this also applies to really any creative
project that I can that I can think
about and to come back to the
brainstorming for a moment when you are
brainstorming what is your personal
preferred method of doing this
whiteboard versus pen and paper versus
typing on a keyboard versus a tablet of
some type how do you like to do it
I am a huge fan of in particular an app
called WorkFlowy and it's a totally free
app and it's basically a series of
nested lists and the nice thing about it
is is it's infinite so I can continue to
make sublists and sublist and sub lists
and I can link pieces to pieces and so I
find over the years now I've been using
that for seven or eight years that is
like my personal favorite tool the
important advice for people is not to
copy the tool whatever works for you
whatever is the easiest flow like the
least resistance right so there's a lot
of people like notion is a similar type
of tool but it's like bulkier and a
little bit slower in my experience and
that speed is everything like I don't
want anything that's going to slow me
down right so that's where pen and paper
is great but I don't like unless I have
a giant sheet of paper which I do enjoy
like if it's a big big like poster board
and like give markers and bigger things
especially if I'm working with a team so
either a giant whiteboard or a large
like poster board on the table because
you can all share the same space and see
ideas form that I think is great but
it's small sheet of paper for me like my
brain when it sees a page start to get
full my brain just subconsciously thinks
okay well you don't need any more ideas
your page is full yeah good it's like
the Goldfish and the fish ball right
it's like all right it's only gonna I'm
not gonna grow anymore this space is
getting a little constrained yeah so I
like workflow because it's got that
infinite kind of growth and I can like
shrink or grow nodes or like okay I want
to dive deeper into this idea and Link
ideas together that's been my favorite
and
what are some of the ways that you like
to prototype and I'd love to know where
you think people most often get stuck
like in between or after which Step do
people get stuck and as someone who's
been as you know because we've had
conversations about this and you've been
incredibly helpful thinking about
prototyping and games and design I've
been very excited about this for a while
now
I tended to get stuck at the prototyping
phase because well it's also my first
sort of rodeo with this but the
inclination is to try to make something
that's like really good and kind of
polished I know I'm not trying to make a
finished product but the more I have
studied what you've done listen to the
podcast talk to people like Ilan Lee or
others
the more I appreciate how quick and
dirty
it is yes and also just as a reference I
think
I have a blog post about Stephen key
who is an inventor product developer
is based in California at least he was
at the time who has done extremely well
developing toys for major companies and
the toys are ultimately some finished
product that look great but he will use
construction paper and like newspaper to
prototype and based on that and a
description and maybe a video of how it
functions he successfully licensed
products all the time to huge companies
so could you speak to maybe the
prototyping phase
you've already hit on the core of this
but I'll just leave it keep it simple
stupid right the kiss principle like it
is the tendency to over develop and make
your prototype super nice or not feel
like you can show it to somebody or test
it without being super nice is the
graveyard of the most games probably of
anything on the planet and the most
ideas frankly in general right so let's
make this very concrete my probably one
of the games I'm most well known for is
a deck building game called Ascension
it's been around for 13 years we've got
lots so I first prototyped that game
there was another deck building game and
a deck building game for those that
don't know it's like it's unlike magic
which is a trading card game where
you're buying packs of cards and trying
to build a deck in a deck building game
you you have a fixed box of cards you
buy it like a box like you would
Monopoly but like during the game you're
acquiring cards for your deck so it's
like you get to play the game of
building a deck right deck building so
there was another deck building game
called Dominion which was released it
was the first of its category and I fell
in love with that game I started playing
it a bunch but then as I played it like
a hundred times I was like you know
there's some really some things I I
would like to see differently I want to
see the cards are too static there's too
many rules and resources I wish I could
change it and so my first prototype of
Ascension was literally just I sh
instead of having Dominion cards which
are all kind of laid out at the
beginning of the game takes like 20
minutes to set up I just shuffle them
all together and dealt them out and said
what would a game look like if it was
randomized and I played that way and the
game was not good but it gave me enough
of a proof of concept that like oh you
know what there's something fun here and
if I spend the time to do this I can now
move forward and just for clarity you
were using the Dominion cards but
changing the rules to see how it
impacted gameplay exactly right so if
you can prototype using something like a
deck of cards around the house or take a
monopoly set I know I keep using
monopolies whatever most people know it
so you know say oh hey what would this
look like if instead of you know going
around go you actually had like
dinosaurs that would like try to eat
each other as you're moving around the
board what would that be like like okay
that sounds kind of fun let's see what
happens right it's literally that simple
so for my prototyping tools my first
round of prototyping is just I have a
bunch of stuff I have a bunch of dice
and you know my D dice with all the
random signs I've got a decks of cards
I've got random pen and paper I will
draw things in fact yeah like when you
and I work together a little bit I
showed you some things you I showed you
what like my early sketch prototypes
look like and they are they are ugly I
talk about like the phases of design
every time you go through the core
design Loop your questions go from
bigger to smaller and smaller and as you
go through it you're going to get more
and more you're going to care about
polish more so if you're just trying to
figure out like where is the fun what is
the idea what's the theme what what am I
doing here you don't want to think about
you know it's like imagine you're
building a house right and before you've
even laid the foundation you're worrying
about the paint color on the walls and
where the furniture goes you're not
going to get very far you're wasting a
lot of time make sure you got a solid
foundation first worry about the paint
color later and so I think a lot of
designers start by worrying about the
paint color being wrong and they're
never going to finish a house that way
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna stand in I
mean this is a lazy sort of rhetorical
trick here but so I'm going to defend
the newbies including myself for a
second
and
ask a question which I think is actually
really
important at the very least helpful in
all sorts of disciplines not just game
design
one of the reasons a lot of writers get
stuck or aspiring writers is that they
kick out a first draft it's rough it's
ugly it's really really rough on all the
edges and they compare their rough draft
to the final draft of
incredible writers
and the rough draft of those writers is
invisible they never see that rough
draft
so what has been helpful to me for
instance when thinking about
potentially writing Comics is seeing the
original scripts and how they were
tweaked and how the concept art was
modified over time to ultimately land on
what we see in the finished product
because then I can see
the ugly babies in the beginning I'm
like oh yeah okay that's very reassuring
and it gives me more confidence to work
with my
ugly baby to try to shape it into
something that ultimately is good
because if I'm comparing everyone's
finished product to my rough product it
can be really demoralizing so the
question is
is there a way for folks to see
the rough drafts of games the
prototyping and so on if they wanted to
explore this as an example
yeah so it's one of the reasons why I I
started my podcast is to sort of unlock
a lot of that stuff for other designers
right talk about their origin stories
talk about the things that inevitably
fail you can also go there are a variety
of places where people will have like
prototype testing so if you want to
let's say you have a favorite game
company or game designers we do this at
stoneblade at my company you can join
our Discord and then we will
periodically put playtest requests out
so that people can because we want to
get feedback right we want to get
feedback people so and they can see how
terrible those games are now we've
already gone through a few iteration
Loops before we put it out into the
public so to see the most raw forms I
think there's not enough of it out there
I think it's something I really want to
encourage more of because it's really
helpful like I've been doing this for 20
years and my first prototypes are
hideous so if you want I can share some
I'll put some up on the think like
gamecenter.com Tim yeah in the show
notes that's great I really want to
demystify that process it is okay in
fact it's better in fact I'll go even
further right because not only is it
faster because you don't you know you
don't get hung up on making it really
pretty it's faster to prototype it's
actually better to change it's easy
because you need to iterate right so if
you put a lot of time into making a
beautiful board and beautiful cards and
then you realize you got to change a
card you're going to feel weird about it
right your sunk cost fallacy is going to
come to latch onto your back I have a
card that I've messed up I'm just going
to cross out something on it with a
marker and write something else and then
okay now it's this go and I'll make a
little note right the resistance to
change is so much lower so it's actually
net negative for you to invest in making
something pretty
early on in the process
makes perfect sense so you've mentioned
your company a couple times but last
time we we left young Justin in our
chronology he was working at a game
design company yes could you fill in the
gaps for us and tell us how you went
from working for somebody else to
working for yourself yeah this is a fun
story and you actually come into the
story Tim so I'll I'll share it so I
moved from working on pure card games
too I had an opportunity to lead a
project that was the World of Warcraft
Miniatures game and this is a very
exciting project for me I get to build
something that's super cool with an IP
everybody knows and I had worked on it
for about 18 months
and we had the company that I worked for
was called Upper Deck they had made
trading cards forever most known for
baseball cards and they made Yu-Gi-Oh
and this Marvel game I'd been working on
but they didn't know how to make
Miniatures games and so they
eventually
if we're gonna kill the project the
executives come and they tell us after
18 months of work this is pretty common
in games but I had never had a project I
had worked on like get killed like that
and I was like devastated right with my
dream project I'm Gonna Change the World
with this game it's going to be
incredible now all of a sudden ashes
I didn't want to let it happen and so I
said listen I don't know what I'm doing
here either but if you're going to kill
the project give me give me six months
let me see if I can figure it out right
you got nothing to lose
and I was able to convince them to let
me become a project manager and try to
figure out how to make games how to make
a miniature game specifically and so
same kind of process like I did when I
first started to design I was like all
right let me talk to people who know
what they're doing I've already got a
very clear deadline
you know I talked to Jeremy Cranford
who's an incredible art director and I
talked to the guy that made the dungeons
of dragons miniature lines I fig I just
work months and months and months try to
figure out how to make this work fly to
China fly to the factory figure out how
the Plastics and paints and all this
crazy stuff and making it work just for
my clarity is making it financially work
for the company that's exactly right
financially how do you make it work
right because blizzard who makes World
of Warcraft had very exacting standards
about their Miniatures they have to have
spiky pauldrons this high and these
amounts of colors and nobody had ever
done anything quite like that before and
it needs to be financially viable to
make this product for for the company I
was working for so that's a partnership
and so
I have to go figure out all these
Logistics set all this stuff up
finally
and this is where I first read the four
hour work week so this is actually it
was super impactful for me in being very
efficient using 80 20 principles and
I've learned to you know set up Auto
email replies so people didn't bother me
so I'm already getting my efficiencies
in it but I'm in this zone of just I'm
gonna finish this mission and then
I
finally go to I have the opportunity to
speak to the executive team right I'm
going to make my presentation or make my
case is this project going to live or is
this project going to die and I'm just
some kid who wants to make a cave and
I've got to convince you know so I'm
there and I will never forget I mean
they had this like ugly Green carpet I'm
sitting waiting for my turn to get
called in it just the details are super
stuck in my mind and I'm like you know
go down this long Corridor and I'm like
my Palms are sweating like I I go you
know you open these huge like oak doors
and this is it's a huge Sportsman beer
company so it's like a Babe Ruth signed
bad on the wall and Michael Jordan
jersey and like a Golf Tiger Woods Golf
Club and the rich mahogany conference
table I mean this is it's it's boardroom
cliche right but it's like very
intimidating for me at this time so I
get up there the owner is like sitting
in this leather chair and like staring
me down and I'm like okay I give my
presentation and I'm
stammering through it but I've done my
research I've done my homework
and I go through the presentation and
you know heart's beaten finally I stop
right and there's this like pause at the
end I'm looking around like what do they
think right it's like CEO CFO like does
all the big wigs right and they start
talking about the idea and they start
like Josh around and I start to think oh
my God I think I think they like it I
think this is really going to happen and
then they start like pontificating and
they start talking oh well there may be
this problem with this thing or this
thing and it took me a minute to realize
this but as they were talking I realized
that they had no idea what they were
talking about like
like I had finally done enough research
that I knew like they didn't know what
they were doing and and like I just had
off to that point in my life I feel like
I had just assumed that you know the
adults in the room knew what they were
doing like this is the same company that
makes hundreds of millions of dollars a
year like of course they know what's
happening
and now all of a sudden that illusion is
shattered and I started out like
terrified of terrified I mean we're
literally this project is gonna you know
it's gonna cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars to make millions or could lose
Millions who knows and nobody knows what
they're doing and so I'm like oh my God
like what do we do and then I walk out
of that room
and I'm like my heart's beating and I'm
just like what's gonna happen how do we
do this and then all of a sudden like a
cold splash of water in my face
nobody knows what they're doing
I cannot know what I'm doing at least as
well as anybody else like this idea that
the difference between a leader and
somebody else is not that they know
something or that they have some special
access is that you're just willing to
make some assertions and own the
consequences that's it that's the
difference
and so then
I finally clicked for me the other parts
of your book right that not just this
efficiency and automation but this idea
of defining what you want and then
creating the freedom for yourself to do
it right and so that's where I suddenly
started doing the fear setting exercise
and go through okay what's the worst
case scenario for me if I quit and I do
my own thing and the dreamlining
exercise which is basically you know
what is it that you really want right
how do you define what you want how do
you make that very concrete and so then
that transform is like okay I'm gonna
get this game out the door I'm Gonna
Save up enough money so I have a year of
savings and and I quit and that's
exactly what I did and it was a
life-changing moment for me because it
was exactly that
taking ownership of my future and again
I'm so grateful for you as a key part of
it and I'm so grateful for those
Executives because they really opened
the door for me you know and I don't
pretend to know what I'm doing all the
time either right it's most of the time
we're making stuff up but it's it's
being conscious about that surfacing our
assumptions and you know learning as you
go it's it's been it's been a powerful
Journey
thank you for sharing that and for
saying all that you said and I would
love to know when you did
the fear setting and you're trying to
identify the worst case how you can
mitigate against the worst case what you
would do as sort of a backup plan in
case the entrepreneurship does not work
out or maybe doesn't work out at least
with the first inning
how are you thinking about that at the
time like what gave you in addition to
what you already described which is the
realization that oh my God almost all
the Emperors have no clothing so I think
I can do that at the very we're at the
very worst I can also do that right how
are you thinking about sort of risk
assessment and what you would do if
things didn't pan out perfectly yeah as
you went into entrepreneurship I got
very concrete so what is my actual
minimal living expenses what do I need
to be okay and have what I need and I
figured out what that number was and
then I was like okay how much time am I
willing to give myself to run this
experiment to see if I can figure it out
and make entrepreneurship work and I
decided a year of savings was what I
wanted and so I focused on saving up so
I have that cushion right because if
you're in the red right if you're like I
don't know how to make my next paycheck
I don't know how to make rent next month
you can't like be creative and be free
you know you're making decisions for the
short term and I want to be able to make
decisions for the long so step one was
have have enough of a cushion that I
could feel comfortable now other other
people can do this you know as a side
project or after hours whatever but for
me I wanted space to just focus on this
and then the other piece was like okay
well what let's assume it doesn't happen
and after a year I've got nothing and
it's not working I had done enough in my
career at that point I could just get
another job like I could either be hired
back at the same place or hired in
another company like it's not like I was
gonna go hungry on the streets or you
know if I have to live on a friend's
couch for a little while that's not that
big a deal either right so I really I
went through all of those things like I
go bankrupt my house catch is on fire
like exit hilariously like like you did
in the book right and so that's where
like it highlights the same kind of
lesson as before which was you know when
I quit law school it sounds scary
everybody thinks oh my God you're such a
risk taker like I'm not I mitigate risk
at every turn it's like when you're
playing Magic and you're trying to like
set up so you can't get outdrawn on a
game I'm just mitigating the number of
ways my opponent could beat me over time
and in this one I could always go back
to law school when I quit law school I
could always go back to a job when I
started as entrepreneurship and same
thing later on when I became a digital
Nomad sold on stuff it's like I could
always buy more stuff I could always get
a house again and so I strongly
encourage people to just go through that
like if you really really think about
the worst case scenarios 99 times out of
100 they're totally recoverable within a
year it's often way less
and what was yours knowing how
methodical you are you were not just
hopping out of this job with savings
with no plan so what was your plan
you know I'm sad to say that it wasn't
that much of a plan I I don't know you
kind of set me up for having a master
plan well I guess with the core design
loop I guess you are going to be
following some version of of that
probably but did you have an inkling of
what type of game or what types of games
you wanted to make
I knew I loved you know obviously card
games were kind of my specialty and so I
knew that that was a space I wanted to
be in
but I really wanted to create that open
space to figure things out and so as you
mentioned of course the core design Loop
was part of it I didn't have it as
clearly defined as I do now but this
idea that like I'm gonna try things and
prototype them and test them and so I
would during the day I would work on
some designs make up some prototypes and
then I would go find my friends who were
still working at the company or
elsewhere to like try it out give me
some feedback and come back and you know
I didn't have any ideas like I didn't I
hadn't designed a game ahead of time I
didn't know what I was gonna do ahead of
time
but I did I had enough space that I
could figure that out and then it worked
out that another person from another
company
contacted me to see if I could do some
contract work for them and so I started
working on some kids toy based games
which was great and so here's another
fun story so they knew me because they
used to work at Upper Deck where I used
to work and then they started working at
this other company and he's like hey we
need someone to help us design a game
can you do that and I'm just like again
no job no plan like I'm just figuring it
out as I go at this point and so I'm
like yep definitely I can do that okay
well give us a quote right I'm like okay
quote how do I quote I've never quoted
anything before so I'm like okay let me
just think about all right how many
hours do I think this is gonna be and
then like what's my minimum like hourly
rate that I think I should be paid and
I'm like okay that's what I'll charge
you know make it easy and I send them
the quote and he literally laughs at my
face she's like yeah okay sure sure man
no problem
wait a second I'm under charging
you know I still try to over deliver do
a great job next time I get another you
know thing opportunities okay what do
you quote I doubled my number they still
laughed at me okay great all right
doubled it again that my strategy was I
kept doubling what I asked for until I
met resistance until someone was like
I'm not sure I'm like okay that's why I
need to be charging
there's one other story I'll just as a
side note mention which which also just
underscores the fact that part of the
frustration but also Joy of
Entrepreneurship is you have to figure
out a lot on the Fly Right you cannot
prepare for all the eventualities you
don't know what you don't know and I
recall I might be misattributing so my
apologies to the founders of Nantucket
nectares if this is misattribution but
when I took my first entrepreneurship
class first and only actually high-tech
entrepreneurship with Professor Ed Shao
who changed my life in so many ways he
used what a lot of people refer to as
the Harvard case study method where you
have sort of a business situation then a
problem and then there's a break and you
have to try to figure it out and then
only after you've had the chance to try
to figure it out on your own as a class
then you read the outcome and the
decision they made and so on and there
was part of this Nantucket nectar story
where these guys are selling juices and
Nantucket and they end up with a tiger
by the tail because their drinks become
really successful and they decide to
make the shift to retail and they meet
with a distributor and they're talking
and talking and Distributors like so do
you have good plans for POS and they're
they like look at each other they have
no [__] idea what he's talking about
they're like oh we have great as for POS
we have we have really we've thought it
through and we think we have we have an
excellent strategy and he's like okay
great and then they leave the meeting
they're like what the hell is Poss point
of sale right displays so it makes for a
lot of good stories so you figure out
you start to figure out your pricing
right by doubling and doubling and
doubling
and
maybe you could flesh that out a little
bit in terms of you're doing this
contract work
for people who are giving you specs
right and of some type or another that's
right but you have some money coming in
the door correct with fewer and fewer
laughs at your proposals along the way
what else is happening in that first
year
so I'm using my kind of spare cycles and
there's this really interesting thing
right the the difference between an
entrepreneur
who has no no employees or anything and
some dude just sitting on his couch can
be very subtle
yeah yeah you know until you start like
really kind of getting income coming in
and start making things happen right so
there was there's definitely a window of
uncertainty
I mean even now even now in my life the
distinction's pretty blurry but yeah it
is you know it's it's it's you know now
I got a team and the people it's like
okay I feel like I got a business but
it's it's not it's not it's not an easy
distinction and when you're trying to
create something where you don't
necessarily know what it is
it's even harder right so what I would
do is I would in between doing this work
for hire I would work on just projects
that I thought would be fun right and so
I would just make prototypes try them
out try them out on friends and I
remember
it was actually with with Ascension
where I didn't make Ascension
specifically to think oh I'm gonna start
a company with this game I made it
because I really wanted that game to
exist like I played enough of dominion
and I like I was missing something I
really really wanted and then I showed
it to a friend of mine Rob Rob Doherty
and he actually was a guy that owned
Your Move games the store where I used
to play when I was younger
and and I show him the game and and he's
like dude you have the ball like run
with it this is this is great make this
a thing and he had been an entrepreneur
for a while and so he helped me kind of
like okay no let's do this and it was
that started down the road and so I like
okay I'm gonna take this this is gonna
be my project now and my early
prototypes were ugly and I will find a
way to share them with you I mean some
of them are like horribly inappropriate
like we are just really just rude
pictures and I won't share those but you
know just ridiculous because it's just
for fun weird pictures how dare you yeah
I'm imagining that's code for lots of
dicks everywhere yeah yeah I'm not I'll
lead to the imagination of the listeners
on this one
not appropriate for public consumption
leave it at that just to defend my
dick's comment I will say there's a
place called Hotel Baron in San
Francisco great wine spot excellent
place and I don't know if this is true
but the re I heard at one point this is
one of the first places with a console
for digital signing way back in the day
and the Rumor was that of all the guys
who went there had bought drinks it's
like 75 just drew dicks as their
signature which I thought I thought was
actually it was pretty hilarious well
there's an important game design
principle I didn't talk about here which
is the TTP
all right which is time to penis
any
opportunity that you give people to
create their own thing at some point
someone's gonna make a dick that's gonna
happen
add that to my metrics key show notes
but I mean so what it is I mean the more
broader point is like anytime you allow
people to customize you have to think
what are they going to do with it and
how does that share and how does that
build your community but TTP the
shorthand for that so it is it is an
unfortunate reality of our society that
that is just gonna happen yeah okay so I
did not see this interview going this
way I'll tell you that right now I
didn't either
thanks [__] punch coffee so all right so
let me let me try to write the ship here
for a second so you're talking about
roughs and the prototypes you'll filter
out some of the rude pictures and we'll
share some of that so when you were
chatting with if I'm remembering
correctly Rob and he's saying you got
this run with this
were you at that point at all thinking
of how it fit into the potentially
competitive landscape and how it was
differentiated or was it just enough for
it to be something that
you used to scratch your own etch and
you assumed hey if this is exciting for
me as one person as someone who plays a
lot of games I assume it's going to be
attractive to more people
so three things right one absolutely it
has to scratch my own itch and I have to
love it right I loved it I wanted to see
it exist all of my most successful
projects by far are the things that like
I make for me and that I really want and
then I know they're gonna be great so
that's I think really important two
I do not Chase Trends I hate chasing
Trends in fact every time I've tried to
chase a trend it's been unsuccessful
right the idea of like I'm trying to
build something for some hypothetical I
think this is hot right now has never
worked however there's a third Point
here which is important which is it
can't be just about you and so the rule
I like to use is I will show the game to
people and I'll prototype it and test it
and when people start asking me to play
again without me prompting them that's
when I know I've got something right so
it's not just me that's why I like Rob
who I respect a lot he was like no no
this is great like play again and I
would show it to some other game
designer friends and show it to some
other people they're like no no this is
great so as you're going through you're
getting like a wider wider sphere of
feedback that's helping you move forward
and if your game is targeted at a
different target audience right so I
make I make a game called Bakugan which
is a toy based game for kids obviously
like how much fun I have playing it is
not nearly as important as as a
five-year-old or an eight-year-old right
so you have to test with your target
market in that sense so so I don't that
you know target market and testing is
not important it is but don't like try
to chase a trend make something that you
know is fun and that you enjoy and then
get the feedback and and iterate as you
go and so as you get that positive
feedback now I'm willing to invest more
and more into the product right so now
I'm I actually I'm gonna go and start
putting some real art on it and the
story behind the art is I guess it's at
this stage I can tell so back when I was
living in Boston
I met the guy that lived down the hall
and he comes in you know comes and
knocks in the door and says hello and I
have like at this time I just moved out
of college so I'm like you know black
light posters on the wall like you know
kind of like it's still basically a
college dorm room I just kind of
transported into an apartment and and
then the guy comes back over like 20
minutes later with like a bag of weed
like I'm pretty sure you want to smoke
this right it's like Okay cool so we
hang out we've become great friends and
he actually turns out he's an incredible
artist his name is Eric saby and he you
know whatever we became friends I have
one of his art pieces on my well not on
my wall anymore but in storage now but
it's actually it's on my little My dad's
place I didn't put that one storage
anyway so 10 years later when I'm making
a game I'm like oh man his art was
really cool I'm gonna call him up and I
called him up and said hey would you
want to be make art for my game and I
built the IP and the story around his
style because I knew I could get this
batch of art without having to pay for
like a whole new artist and new thing
since he'd already made it so I could
pay him less and he was a good friend
and he looked it up and so so now I
start bringing art into the game and
figuring out how you can you know use
what's around and build the lore and
build a style around what's available
now okay now we've made some art now
we've got some cool looking cards and so
I'm investing a little bit more and then
I take it to a convention called gamma
which is a game manufacturers
Association event it's like an industry
Insider tabletop game thing so
Publishers and retailers and
Distributors are all there so not a
public show and I get a little booth and
I bring my little fake prototype there
and I realized actually as I was going
to the show that I didn't have in the
game you get what's called honor which
like victory points basically and I
forgot to bring like make anything that
you track how do you track how many
points you get how many honor you get
and I was like oh man what do we do and
I went to a like a Michael store you
know like a like a little craft store
craft store yes thank you and they had
these little beads these little plastic
like Fishbowl beads you know and they're
all the oddly shape it's like all right
whatever let's try these I'll just use
these for the Prototype so grabbed a
bunch of those put them in and we start
demoing the game and people get drawn to
these beads and like oh my God this is
awesome it's like crows just finding a
shiny button yes exactly they're super
shiny and they come over and like are
these uh and they you know they play the
game they like the games like oh this is
awesome these are going to be in the
game right I was like yes yes they are
this is like the POS example you gave
earlier I have no idea how to get these
things I have no idea how to make them I
don't know what's going but they are
definitely really in the game anyway so
so that show the response was so
overwhelming like the people loved it
stores wanted to order it Distributors
want to order so now all of a sudden
it's like okay now I'm gonna literally
I'm all in right I put my entire life
savings now all the extra that I'd saved
up to print at the time was ten thousand
units of the game which is pretty crazy
probably a little over it sounds like a
lot of units it was a lot of units yeah
most times people are going to start a
new game it's like you print a thousand
units maybe three thousand units yeah
you better hope to God you don't have a
manufacturing anomaly yeah oh dude I was
Nightmare stories around that for sure
that's a that's a whole different Beast
but again I had worked with
manufacturers before I had made games
working for another company so this part
wasn't totally new to me but it was and
I wouldn't have put all of that money
into the thing you know I used to joke
if this doesn't work I'm gonna have to
build a house out of Ascension boxes you
know it's pretty much all I got but I
wasn't again just a demystify the risk
right I just I had gotten so much
positive feedback I had stores and
Distributors already waiting to order
the thing so now it's like okay it's
willing to put the money in and take a
risk and also just for for folks who are
unaware I mean there are all sorts of
ways to
potentially finance things if you have
that demonstrated demand I'm not
suggesting this you got to do your own
diligence on these things but like
invoice factoring right like if you have
people are pledging and signing whatever
it is letters of intent or something
more binding to purchase a certain
quantity you can use that with
manufacturers to then get Finance terms
and yes there are companies that
independently do this as well so ways to
work around it my question
that I want to ask next is related to
gamma how many
exhibitors or people with games like
yourself game developers were there at
the show actually it's not we don't even
need to be specific to game developers
like how many
booths or exhibits were at this show
at the time I think it was like about
30. oh okay all right it's not huge you
know and now it's it's bigger maybe
maybe two or three times that but it's
not like you know it's not I guess less
than 100. okay got it so no no that's
one of the nice things the game
Industries is still a little smaller
than like a a New York toy fair is the
more big one that's like
it happens and that's got thousands and
thousands of booths and you're spending
millions of dollars to have a presence
there it's like a much bigger piece this
is this one's a little smaller the
reason I'm asking is that in fact if
somebody wants just a separate
collection of stories around these steps
to trade shows and I think it was the
New York Toy Fair Todd McFarland the
legendary comic book artist has some
stories around this from our
conversations which are hilarious
what I was wondering and maybe it
doesn't apply because there were 30
tables or 30 booths but did you do
anything to draw attention to yourself
or the game at this event or was it
simply enough to pay for a booth and
then
assume that there would be enough foot
traffic to bring the right people to you
so the principal you're driving at is
critical right you need to get people's
attention you need to find a way at
these booze even you know a Gen Con
which is the more public-facing table
convention where I actually did launch
Ascension and there's a lot more people
and a lot more vying for traffic at
shows like gamma anywhere why or even on
a store shelf right why is someone going
to stop and pay attention to what you're
doing the great thing about where we are
in our modern world is it's easier than
ever to make stuff you can print your
own books you can print your own games
on demand you can make anything you want
the downside is we're flooded with stuff
not surprising and so how do you
separate from the crowd how do you draw
people's attention so at Gamma I mean I
already told you by accident almost the
shiny beads helps nobody had those shiny
beads that was a really attractive thing
but I also invested in a a video Drop
Like I had a TV screen and I made like a
little cool rotating Loop showing the
things and people most people there
didn't do that and so finding something
that draws people's eye and brings them
in so it can be a cool unique component
it can be a cool giant visual it can be
I had I had a game I launched years
later called bad beats b-e-t-s it's like
kind of play on the poker term of bad
beats but with actual beats I had
someone dress in a giant beat costume I
put one of my team members into a giant
beat costume right and yeah it's
gimmicky but it worked right so if you
have a great product it doesn't matter
if nobody ever looks at it right and
also all the gimmicks in the world don't
won't help you if you don't have a great
product so step one have something great
step two have a reason for people to pay
attention to you
yeah the workshopping attention grabbing
in real life I think is really
undervalued in today's increasingly
digital world and this applies to for
instance workshopping book material by
giving speaking engagements even to a
very small group you'll figure out very
quickly what works and what doesn't
what's confusing and what isn't what
people will remember versus what they
immediately forget or didn't even pay
attention to in the first place and the
the trade show stories are bringing back
memories because I recall when I back in
my former life had my Sports Nutrition
Company and I would go to these
these trade shows and as you know I have
to imagine this is true for these other
trade shows
once you get there you are a captive
audience and if you want to share it's
like oh yeah you can rent a chair for
300 bucks for you know a day and I was
just going in somewhat naive because I
paid the exhibitor fee and I was like oh
great I'll like I'll figure out the rest
shouldn't be too bad but it was pretty
bad so I remember trying to figure out
how to draw attention
and at one particular trade show I I
next to no budget because there were a
couple of things that were mandatory
that you had to rent which struck me as
a little bizarre but it exhausted my my
budget so what I ended up doing was also
getting I bought a TV at Best Buy a big
screen that I could return
and I put on
highlight reels of Muay Thai kickboxing
right because it's like it's definitely
gonna grab some attention but to provide
a little context this was at a
it was a strong man slash sports event
it was kind of like the Arnold Classic
in Columbus for people who might know
that it's a that's a huge event this was
much smaller but there were a lot of
athletes and competitors and so on
Milling about and I also brought I think
it was four or five of these hand
grippers called the captains of crush
which are incredibly
and increasingly difficult to close
depending on the poundage to the extent
that some of them are
are so difficult that there are maybe
five or six people or 12 people in the
world who at that time could close
whatever the highest rated captains of
crush was so I laid those out for people
to test with all these athletes Milling
about and then put this video up
ended up getting the couch and chairs at
a good will and I had to like bribe a
guy to help me with this truck to get it
oh yeah and it ended up being a really
hilarious experience but it taught me a
lot about what worked and what didn't
and I was able to iterate because it was
a multi-day event
and
taking a step back for a second and then
I want to come back to to Ascension and
all the adventures there what have you
learned about
good play testing versus not terribly
effective play testing what I mean by
that is when you're providing your game
to people certainly one pass fail is do
they want to play it past the point that
you need them to play that's sort of
like the Viagra test right like send it
out to test patients for whatever it was
hypotension hypertension something like
that and then lo and behold like all
these guys over the age of X didn't want
to send back their medication and it's
like huh interesting let's look at that
that's how Viagra came to be in its
current iteration but there's that and
the reason I'm asking this and this is
going to be a very long paragraph
question is that
when I am doing the equivalent with my
books and chapters
there are definitely better and worse
ways to elicit feedback if you're like
what do you think of this chapter it's a
crap shoot and if people are trying to
be nice which comes down to who you
select also to be your play testers in
my case proofreaders
you're gonna get
a bit of a scatter shot of responses and
it might not be actionable but if I ask
read this chapter tell me you know the
20 that I should absolutely keep no
matter what and if you then tell me the
20 if you had to cut 20 that you would
cut
you're going to get very very different
type of kind of surgical feedback
similarly to someone who's maybe less
experienced as a as a reader you could
just say note any place that is
confusing or where you find your mind
wandering yes and then that gets you to
also stuff that you might cut
what have you learned about
eliciting feedback or evaluating
feedback when you're letting people test
a game
it's going to depend upon the phase that
you're in right so there is a every time
I go through the core design loop I like
to think of myself like a scientist
right I have some hypothesis that I'm
trying to test and that's what I'm
focused on in that testing session so
when you're early on you're like okay is
this even fun is this idea of like
rolling dice to try to punch somebody
and making combos font right or whatever
it is right you want to just see is it
fun I'm not asking is it balanced I'm
not asking is it pretty I'm not asking
does the game last too long I'm asking
is this part fun and that's what I'm
focused on and so I know when I'm
testing that if I start getting feedback
on these other parts I'm not worried
about that I can set that aside because
that's not what I'm looking for here and
the whole I want to keep playing I want
to play again test the Viagra test as
you put it that's not going to come true
until later on in the cycle right your
early prototypes are most likely not
going to meet that right so you're
looking for other things so
I do like you so I have a questionnaire
that I'll use I have it it's up for free
I think like a game designer.com Media
or we can link it in the show notes
which has a bunch of specific questions
you can just print it out and use it so
I will ask all right what are the three
things you like the most about the game
what are the three things you like the
least about the game where did you get
confused
and much like your book question right
you really want to pay attention to
where people get lost and confused and
non-verbal communication is at least as
important as anything they're going to
write down and tell you because people
if you say give me the three things you
like the most three things you like the
least what would you change whatever
people will say something to you just
because they feel like they have to say
something to you right it doesn't always
mean that that's really what they feel
right you're prompting them to it so you
have to use your intuition to say okay
where a is this relevant to the
hypothesis I'm trying to test in the
stage that I'm in B does this align with
what I see visually of what they're
doing right like my mom tells me she
loves all my games even when she really
has no idea what's going on in some of
them right she's very nice but if I see
that somebody's getting lost or leaning
back or checking their phone like
watching for those non-verbal cues is so
important and you sort of train yourself
over time to get better at that
but yeah so asking questions to prompt
for the specifics being focused on
what's important to me right now
looking for nonverbal cues and then in
best case scenario just like you
mentioned right you have some more
sophisticated readers and you have less
sophisticated readers you have more
sophisticated game players and less
sophisticated gameplay so if you can
test with other game designers they're
going to be better at zeroing in and
okay yeah I don't care that the card
doesn't have pictures on it or that the
numbers aren't balanced I I know what
you're looking for and I give you
feedback assigned to it if you just take
it to somebody you know just a regular
person they're gonna get hung up on a
lot of little things and so you have
their their feedback's a little bit
harder to you know you have to parse out
a little bit more of what's important of
course as you get more and more focused
on the final product somebody that's in
your target audience their feedback
matters a lot and then the last thing
I'll say is a quote that's I think is
also one of your favorites it's
definitely one of mine from Neil Gaiman
they when your reader says that
something is wrong they're almost always
right and when they say how to fix it
they're almost always wrong right so I
don't know if I'm butchering it but that
is 100 True in games too right if you
get your testing with multiple people in
your target audience that are
consistently saying that something's not
good you as a designer have to fix it
they definitely do not have the right
answer for how to fix it that's your job
but that's another key part when I'm
testing is that okay I'm looking for
themes looking for patterns one person
telling me they don't like something
maybe I can dismiss it but if 20 people
that are all in my target audience say
that that's something I got to focus on
yeah no matter how pretty the paragraph
no matter how shiny the Fishbowl Pebble
you might have that's right if a bunch
of people are saying I don't get it it's
confusing you gotta cut it
not always the easiest thing so what
happened with Ascension so you you have
enough Ascension kits to build a house
or at least you put in the order that's
right and what unfolds so then I go and
I get a booth at Gen Con as mentioned
and this was the where I'm going to have
the unveiling and now again I'm I'm very
poor at this point now Gen Con for folks
who don't know can you just maybe paint
a picture or an analogy for for what Gen
Con is and the significance of Gen Con
yeah so Gen Con is the tabletop and
role-playing game Mecca of the United
States possibly you could say the world
right Jen from Lake Geneva is where it
started it's why it's called Gen Con
it's not there anymore but that's what
it came from where the original Dungeons
and Dragons people got together and
played it was like the first place where
people started gathered and it kind of
built this core of what gaming became
today and so now it happens in
Indianapolis it's like 60 000 people
every year somewhere in that
neighborhood and every type of game you
can imagine people are playing all hours
of the night you know they call it the
best four days in gaming but it's got
anything you can dream of is there and
many things you can't dream of so it's
like kind of the place to be if you will
for for tabletop and role-playing game
nerds like myself
all right so you show up at Gen Con
you've gone from 30 booths to God knows
how many right you can't count how many
and I'm just I'm just a little guy right
I don't have any I have no company
you're at a Taylor Swift concert now
yeah right exactly exactly and so what I
had was I I bought a 10 by 10 booth
which is the smallest Booth you can ten
foot by 10 foot booth and then they had
like a like a kind of newbie competition
like a little submit your marketing plan
and we can give you a 10 by 20 booth for
the price of a 10 by 10 and I won that
contest so fortunately got a 10 by 20
Booth which is still very small in the
scheme of what's there and I set up my
stuff and this was people had started to
hear about my game because I showed it
off at Gamma before and I start putting
it out there in whatever way I can but
this is just posting online and sharing
with friends I don't have any marketing
budget or anything like that whatever I
can get right and then I get there and
not only do we have like we have some of
the early adopters who had heard about
it run to the booth but then they play
the game
and they loved it so much they would
then take it open up buy it open it up
and then start showing it to their
friends they would like set up and and
so we ended up this is not allowed a Gen
Con anymore by the way but they would
just take over like nearby tables like
at a seated area and just start demoing
the game for me like totally for you
know didn't ask them to didn't pay them
the Ascension Splinter cells activate it
did and I would start seeing people play
it in the halls and then I would see
people carrying boxes around and so it
became this kind of like viral before
you know we you know this sort of viral
sensation in a way that was very
it was very exciting it was like a very
incredible moment and so we sold out of
everything we brought and then I had a
really
interesting this is a very rewarding
very cool experience my team you know
it's not just me now I've got other
people there like working really hard to
make this come to life teams like four
of us
and and then I got an offer
that was very difficult to offer to
refuse so I at this point I had early
product that was shipped for Gen Con but
the rest of the stuff was still on the
way so I still haven't sold these 10 000
units with all my life savings tied up
into it and I get a call from another
very very big gaming company and I don't
think I'll say the name just because I
don't know anyway and they say hey we
like your game we want to buy it out all
of it we'll take it over it'll be our
game we'll pay you a royalty you don't
have to worry about anything it'll be
all done now this is a very tough moment
for me in a sense it's a dream come true
they buy all the stock so my money's off
the table
they are a big company they can push it
they can sell it and then I can just go
back to making games and I'll have some
amount of royalty you know and that'll
be good to go
and I sat with it and at the end of the
day I was like you know what
this is my baby I've worked so hard to
get it here and I just I want to see it
through I want to see it through I want
it to stay mine I didn't want to sell it
off and
I said no and it was like one of those I
might regret this one later right and
and then
30 days later product shows up finally
after delays
funnily enough the product launch delay
was launched such that it actually
launched while I was at Burning Man
which was not not supposed to be but
there was
and when I come back from burning man so
I have a little release party like out
on the middle of the desert on the ply
and
when I come back it's sold out
everything was sold out the entire run
and we had to make a reorder and it was
like okay now I can actually the company
is it's working I can reorder start
making expansion and start and like the
rest of the company's history kind of
evolved from that in a way that well I'm
glad I made the decision I did all right
many questions
at Gen Con how many games did you sell
roughly
oh man I don't remember exactly but it's
a hundreds hunt some number of times
yeah
so I want to bookmark this this is not
going to be my first question but just
how you sell 10 000 after selling a few
hundred right was it Word of Mouth
online was it something else just what
factors do you think contributed to that
because it's not an immediate
obvious outcome right at least not not
for me listening to the story but before
we get to that because this all sort of
undergirds a lot of what you're talking
about
how did the economics of say tabletop
games or card games work right like
what's the kind of traditional model how
do people get paid who's getting paid
like what what are the percentages is
terms of royalties is it what is that a
percentage of can you just give us an
overview of what the economics of that
world kind of look like as a template
sure so when you're producing games
right you typically most of the time
you're going to produce them overseas
some now with cardboard stuff it's
starting to become a little bit more
economical to do it Stateside we do some
of our games Stateside but mostly you
don't do it overseas and your whatever
the retail price of the game is you
typically need the cost of the game has
to be about a fifth of that right and
the reason is that as a manufacturer you
are going to sell the game to a
distributor at about 60 off the price of
retail they're going to sell it to a
retailer at 50 off the price of retail
so they've got like a 10 margin for
distribution and then the retailer has
that 50 margin for the rest estimate so
if you're manufacturing if you are a
game designer and manufacturer then it
sounds like 20 margins generally on
games yeah something like that yeah now
if you're a game designer typically if
you have an external game designer and
you're going to pay you pay a royalty to
that Designer off whatever you're
selling right so if you're selling it to
distribution you sell a percentage off
the distribution price if you sell it
direct to Consumer yourself to Consumer
Price and that can vary depending upon
the designer so in tabletop games
typically it's going to be anywhere
between six and 12 percent at the super
hot at the high end for more mass Market
games big scale games it can go as low
as two percent or three percent but
somewhere okay got it in that ballpark
this is important because it highlights
how
challenging
your decision to say no
was right because we're not talking
about like I'm keeping 90 well I mean
maybe with direct consumer you are but
it's not like 90 margins versus six it's
like there's actually a narrower Gap
right which is also true for instance in
books for self-publishing and
traditional deals people think they're
miles and miles apart in some cases
maybe they are but when you start to
factor in all of the costs
the the Delta between the percentage
that you take say self-publishing versus
traditional it's not as wide as people
might think so
thank you for giving that is there
anything else you'd like to add to that
yeah well you know it comes down to it
was a little bit more than just
the money and the dollars in the sense
of it it was just it was a matter of
like this was my
baby this is my IP right if you you've
worked with Publishers where they now
take over the rights of stuff and you
can't just do what you want with the
book anymore you can't do it right I
would imagine if you want to do like
Ascension expansion packs or Ascension A
B C D and E you want to do a whole
derivative line if the publisher owns
those rights or effectively owns those
rights
you're in a tight spot that's right and
now think about where we are now 13
years later there's over 16 Standalone
expansions for Ascension we made
Ascension tactics which is an Ascension
Miniatures game which we did another
expansion to that Ascension has been
featured in a major motion picture we
are you know working on trying to take
the IP and make cartoons and make other
things comic books out of it right all
there's all of these things that are fun
right like you know we've had
conversations about this sort of stuff
like it's fun to create and grow and
expand your story lines you know when I
first made Ascension I had I had
sketched out a three-year story arc of
like what the world of Ascension would
be if I you know got the whole thing
done and now of course it's 13 years
later so I've had to make some more
stories since then but that's the part I
love like growing up playing Dungeons
and Dragons like the the process of
coming up with the stories and making it
and bringing that world to life is just
I love it and so I didn't want to to
lose that and I don't you know for
people that are listening that are
trying to make these decisions like it's
not obvious even though I've been
fortunately successful with it's not
obvious that it's the right decision for
everybody like I spend way less of my my
time just designing games because I'm
running a company right I have to do I
have to manage Logistics I have to
manage people I have to you know kind of
plan out the marketing strategies
there's all these things that come with
running a company and so I think a lot
of people would actually be better off
in the way all you want to do is make
games then selling to a publisher is a
great is a great strategy I wanted to
build worlds and build something bigger
and so here I am
and I'll just repeat a name I mentioned
earlier Stephen key I don't think he
does what some people would refer to as
venturing which is basically building
the business to do it mostly yourself or
a lot of it yourself
he loves developing new toys and new
products and he's really good at the
licensing game and that as far as I know
maybe things have changed but that's the
game he plays and I would say just on
the do something bigger side there are
different ways of doing something bigger
right so if you want to have the freedom
to do the extensions and so on like you
have
on some level you almost certainly have
to retain rights
but for a product developer who doesn't
have or doesn't doesn't have the
business know-how or doesn't want to
develop it doesn't want to spend time
that way you know licensing to a
gigantic company that has a global
footprint and distribution could be the
perfect path or the best available path
for making a large impact in terms of
distribution and having some type of
putting a spin on the ball of culture
well yeah speaking of putting a spin on
the ball the game Bakugan I mentioned
earlier is a game that I work on that's
Spin Masters the company owns it they
have toy plastic balls and there's a
game that I designed the game but they
own the rights they own the game they
own the distribution they do everything
and that is by far the biggest
quote-unquote game I've ever worked on I
mean it's it's all over the world it's
in toy stores anywhere you go there's a
cartoon multiple cartoons like it's
enormous and so that is also fun and
also a really cool exciting thing and so
that path is totally viable so you can
do work for hire you can create projects
and sell them and make a royalty you can
launch and publish your own things
there's there's an enormous number of
ways to go forward and a lot of it comes
down to just getting clear defining what
it is that you want what's important to
you it's like how do I make a living as
a game designer that's like the surface
level question the how questions are a
trap right you need to get below that
it's like wait what does it mean for me
like what is it I actually want what
does success look like for me and then
even deeper than that why am I doing
this right because I want to make super
cool worlds and I want to grow into a
universe or because I want to
collaborate with people or because I
want to reach millions of people or
because I just want to have something to
play with my friends and do something on
the side right those questions there's
no wrong answer to any of those
questions but if you don't dive deep
enough for yourself you're going to end
up chasing down a path like I did many
times where I'm just going to compete or
move on a path for the sake of it
because I want the most dollars I mean
it's that is the most dollars it's the
wrong game to play I'll tell you that
yeah totally it's uh it can it can lead
you astray really quickly
important to keep your eyes on the cash
flow but also yes it can be a trap don't
run out of dollars but don't just
optimize for dollars all right so maybe
this ties in you've mentioned a number
of of successes do you have a in your
entrepreneurial Journey after starting
your company any favorite failures or
near-death experiences or anything like
that that you can describe oh yes oh yes
I can
the the life of an entrepreneur is
definitely one that has a lot of ups and
downs as of many of your guests could
attest to it you can attest I'm sure
and so what I mentioned earlier the game
soulforge we've since relaunched it but
at the time it was a purely digital
trading card game and I partnered with
Richard Garfield right this is the guy
that created Magic the Gathering this is
a dream come true for me and I'll tell
you the brief story like so we meet
we're at a game conference you know like
I'd seen him around before but we hadn't
really met and uh we're at a game
conference called Pax Dev it's like a
developer conference
and he's giving a talk on design so of
course I'm in the audience listening
because I want to learn from the master
and he says at the end there's a q a and
then somebody asks him hey what's your
favorite game right now and he says
Ascension and I literally like jump up
out of my seat from the back of the
audience and like like a stupid kid
right everybody laughs but it gives me
the opening and so I go and I start a
conversation with him after the talk and
we start talking and we get excited it's
clear we're both excited about the same
project and so soul for just born
now this was a project that was my first
digital game I'd ever done and I
was a little cocky at this point I won't
lie I succeeded my first project
Ascension was a huge success everything
I touched turns to Gold it's all going
to be great we're doubling in size every
year
and we do a crowd fund and I thought it
was going to cost like 250 000 to make
that game
and we crowdfund with that Target and we
end up crowdfunding double that gold
near almost double that goal like 500
000 it's like oh this is amazing we're
gonna crush it we're so good
and as it turns out making digital games
is very expensive and that costs three
million dollars to me oh man and so I
had to go and try to raise funds again
and you know we have to launch the game
before we're ready and again we have
followers we have cash but the cash burn
is over time I can see the cash burn is
higher than the income and it's not
working and I overextend I start
borrowing more money I start trying to
like I know I can make this work I'm not
gonna let it go like this is my baby I'm
Gonna Keep it going how are you raising
and borrowing money just if you don't
mind adding a little more detail so it
starts off with kind of friends and
family you know convertible notes
kind of round so that means like they
give me a loan and then in theory it
turns into a into Equity over time as we
get yeah and then after that then I
start taking some of those refactoring
loans like you talked about right so I'm
getting loans against my future income
on ascension to pay for soul Forge and
then you know starting to run up credit
cards and like all the things are really
are not supposed to do yep and I get to
a point where I have to like finally
realize like wow I'm I'm gonna go
bankrupt like I can't do this anymore
like I'm gonna lose everything and this
was just one of the hardest things that
I have ever faced because not only is it
like I feel like I owe it to my team who
I'm gonna have to lay off these people
whose livelihoods depend on it we have
fans and people who love the game and in
a traditional tabletop game if I stop
making Ascension let's say right you
still have your copy of Ascension at
home and you can play it for as long as
you want doesn't matter if I don't make
any more but when I turn on when I stop
making software it's a digital game that
means the servers turn off that means
your entire collection is gone that
means you can't play it on everything
you spent it's all gone so I'm like
failing myself I'm failing my team I'm
failing the fans like everything and I
have to make some very very hard
decisions and not to mention the friends
and family of course yeah I literally
have my parents had taken a loan against
their house to help me at one point I
mean this is I am so overextended I am
so like in the thick of it and shame and
it is tough and I have to
come to a realization and come to the
other side of it where I had to like go
through this process of accepting I had
to get to the other place like okay
it happened I've lost everything I
failed now what right now there's a
different kind of fear setting exercise
because now I'm on the other side of my
worst nightmare and I
you know took me a little while but I
was like okay you know what
I will still be alive
I will be able to pay off some of these
debts over time with some other things I
can recover from this it's going to be
okay the people who got laid off they're
going to get another job right like it
was not easy but then I once I accepted
that worst case outcome and then I was
able to say okay now how do I make this
less likely and so I
had to lay people off but I also
renegotiated debts and negotiated
payment plans and reduced our overhead
and took on more contract work and like
slowly but surely I was able to dig
myself out of the hole and I don't think
there's any chance I would have been
able to do that if not for being
mentally ready with okay I've lost it
all right I'm talking to bankruptcy
attorneys right and that gives you a
different kind of attitude and approach
when you're trying to you know you're
negotiating with a lender that you owe
money to they're like you owe me money
you should collect them like I know but
either I'm gonna go bankrupt you're not
gonna get anything or we're gonna work
something out and I'm gonna I'm gonna do
my best to pay you off
and so fortunately I was able to turn
that around and
not only did I learn you know the
important lessons like you can go
through a lot and you can recover from
it but also to you know not put myself
in that position again right not to
overextend to that degree and learn to
make smaller bets and grow as you can it
was a very important and powerful thing
which then of course I'm now able to
been able to come back to with
reinvigorating that very same game
so to ask a question related to that
you have this dream come true
partnering with Richard to create this
game
how did you two communicate or what led
to
the ability to maintain that
relationship and now work together again
right because there are I suppose as I'm
imagining different ways this could have
played out I'm sure there are ways with
many different collaborators where
things could have exploded and it would
have damaged the relationship and that
would have been the end of that so why
didn't that happen
you got to be honest with people right I
mean like that's that's really what it
comes down to like act in Integrity when
you work with Partners right you
sometimes you have bad news you tell
them bad news if you have some humility
around when you're
ideas are not working or when you're
trying things and say Here's what we're
going to do and here's what you know
that when I talk about like nobody knows
what they're doing I realize the other
Executives do it I don't hide the fact
that I don't know what I'm doing I've
learned a lot I've got good ideas I've
tried things that work but whenever
you're pushing the boundary and trying
something new sometimes it's not going
to work and so when you're working with
somebody and you know again
unfortunately Richard has been he's
professional he's not only he's made
games that were Uber successful but he's
also made plenty games that weren't Uber
successful too right so he knows this
anybody that's done this for long enough
any creative field you just you cannot
predict everything is not going to be a
hit and so when it's my first major
failure for me it felt like the end of
the world but the more you work with
professionals the more you realize that
that's just part of the process amazing
what if you
learned or what decisions have you made
related to your company or
entrepreneurship how you run things
that you think
are worth mentioning it could be after
that experience it could just be in
general maybe ways that you have
simplified things or challenged
assumptions turned things upside down
anything at all that comes to mind
one of the things that I've realized is
that the same way you design games
designing a great game and design a
great company are not all that different
in a great game you have clear goals you
know what you're trying to do it's very
clearly defined what you're trying to do
you're getting a lot of feedback and
rewards right either that be from points
or achievements or experience right
you're getting constant feedback loops
the challenge level is appropriate
you're focused on learning one thing at
a time the skill level is appropriate
where you want to be and probably the
most important thing about games when we
play games we take a certain kind of
mindset if I'm playing a game and I I
expect to lose I expect to have
challenges in fact that's the whole
point right if you play a game and
there's never a challenge
why are we even doing it right and so I
have tried to cultivate all four of
those things in my company right we set
clear goals where it's like okay we're
going to try to
have this metrics this specific metric
like our email subscriber list we're
going to try to increase it by this
amount and here's how we're going to do
it over this quarter or we're going to
try to get a new game in this category
that we're going to have a prototype
ready to go in two weeks right clear
goals we have something that allows us
to have daily focus and feedback what I
love is the rule of three I think I
first learned this from Chris Bailey
for his book The productivity project
but I've applied it at every level of my
company so
what it is is you have everybody post
their three daily goals right what are
the top three things that I want to
focus on and three is really important
because we all have an infinite laundry
list of stuff to do right we're never
going to finish our to-do list but if
you can finish your most important three
things you can make an enormous amount
of progress and so and we scale that to
every level of the company so every team
we have we have three weekly goals we
have monthly goals we have quarterly
goals and so everything kind of scales
down and I even built this into my own
like personal life like I have a thing
the level up Journal which I've made
which I've got it just has a journal
that just it fits in your pocket and has
three goals three habits and then a
little gratitude practice and and so
every piece of it by focusing on very
few things and making those the priority
it makes a big difference and then
lastly with the mindset we set very
aggressive goals and it's okay not to
hit them right like a game when you want
to win you take winning seriously but
you don't cry when you lose a game right
you say okay what did we what can we
learn from this how do we get better and
starting to take that attitude and
approach it sometimes easier than others
for sure but like cultivating that
mindset and focusing on what's important
and making sure that the goals are clear
and everybody knows what they are and
you're moving day to day that's that's
how I structure the company and it's
again it came from just the principles
of design applying them to to what we do
and I found it to be really powerful
if people in the company are posting for
instance the the rule of three there's
three priorities for the day where are
they posting these so we have a company
Discord so we'll have a we have a
channel in our company Discord that
everybody posts their three goals for
the day this is a separate one for
weekly goals separate one for monthly
goals and a separate one for quarter
legals and so you could always look back
and see what everybody is doing at any
given point if you care to at the main
focus it helps also helps us stay
connected right because we're 100 remote
team now so even though I may not talk
to a given person or see a given person
I can quickly glance and see what's most
important to them right now right and
then so it keeps us all connected and
accountable
two questions the first is is there any
follow-up on those three or is it just
the act of someone publicly stating
their priorities that makes everyone
feel connected and hopefully gives them
some felt sense of accountability that
you think leads to sort of better
output let's start there
so the daily there's not much follow-up
on The Daily it's about staying
connected and I think it just forces you
to plan right it forces you to assess
for yourself okay what actually is
important to me a lot of people will
just start checking emails and going
down rabbit holes and they're working
they are working but they're not doing
what's important right they're just
doing whatever's in front of them and so
this forces just as a habit it forces
you to think things through great point
then for the weeklies we do have that so
we have our weekly goals we have a
check-in at the end of the week where
people will post hey here were my goals
for last week here's how they went here
are now my goals for the next week or
well you know what can I do if I didn't
meet a goal what am I doing to fix it so
there is some accountability and I read
through those every week for the team
and we discuss and that's on Friday so
people are setting their priorities for
the following week on Friday correct got
it and why Discord versus other tools
how did you choose it so we've tried a
lot of them I'm obsessed with
productivity tools
as you are I think with a lot of these
things for some sometimes to a fault but
so we tried slack we tried a couple of
other custom ones we tried to sauna we
tried Monday we tried a bunch of them
but the nice thing about Discord is one
it's
very easy to use very you could just
start up a channel for free you can have
voice chat and text chat you can also
upload bigger files than you can with
like slack restricts that unless you
have a paid program that's much easier
to like load files and share things and
honestly Discord started as like a gamer
focused thing and so we actually built
our fan community in Discord so you can
go to the stoneblade Discord and it's
like it's kind of funny because it's
sort of like a like a front of the shop
back of the shop kind of vibe right so
it's like the front of the shop is right
all the fans are there they're all
chatting about the games we can jump in
and chat with them and then we're in the
sort of private channels that are you
can't see but we're talking about making
the next things that you know you're
going to be talking about six months
from now and so it's like automatically
gives us a sense of like connection to
our fans because the same place where
we're doing our work one click away you
can see and interact with fans so it has
a nice bonus effect of of making us feel
a little bit more connected to the
community
how much of your work do you do on
laptop versus phone
like percentage would you say 90 plus
percent laptop for sure
my phone is I'll occasionally check
emails to make sure I'm not missing
anything but I hate working on my phone
yeah I figured it was probably something
like that I'm the same way what is the
mobile experience with Discord like I've
never used it on mobile it's fine I mean
it you know again so mostly when I'm
there I can I can check messages I turn
off all notifications for everything I
don't want my phone bothering me or
pinging me or distracting me like I am
using my phone consciously because I
want to look at something specific so it
means I have a meeting and I'm not at my
desk I'll go to Discord go to the
meeting thing check it or I have
something I want to post at a public
Channel this is another key thing about
it that's great because you have so many
different channels and you can make
threaded discussions one of the things I
try to encourage is that we have as much
as possible make Communications public a
lot of times people have side chats and
side conversations that come up with
some great idea and then it will get
lost because people are just in a
private Channel somewhere and so we'll
make sure that people have public
discussions as much as possible so
people can add comments and can get
involved and stay connected if they want
to but
to continue with your question the
mobile experience it's mostly just for
some I will only use it if it's like
there's some specific communication or
meeting or connection I need to do
that's when I'll use my phone if I'm
going to work it's because I'm set up at
a laptop
designating time to work and connect
all right we could keep going for hours
and and maybe we will do more rounds but
there's a
prompt here
that I would love to explore which is
how a trip to Thailand helped you to
escape your need for control all right
so as someone who focuses on systems
predictability controllability
Etc
this might be therapeutic for me to hear
so I could you unpack this for us yes so
I think we're very similar in the sense
Tim it's not I wouldn't call myself a
control freak just because I don't want
to say mean things about myself but I
very much want things to be good and I
believe I know how to make them good and
I want to make sure that they are good
right so that's what control freaks say
so the point being like look I know I'm
good at my job and for the most part
with the most of the jobs that people
are doing I know how to do them
as well as they do that's how I know if
they're doing a good job or not right
this is the story I'm telling myself and
I hired a lot of very smart very capable
people and I ended up every extra person
I hired suddenly became more work for me
because I had to keep checking to make
sure that they were on track or setting
up more systems to you know have this
and and if they weren't doing something
the way I thought they should be coming
in or they would come to me with
questions
and at some point I'm like listen this
is too much this has gone kind of crazy
I'm gonna
I need to step away and so I said look
I'm gonna take a three-week trip to
Thailand I'm not bringing my laptop I'm
not bringing my you know I'm not
reachable I'm gonna do that in six
months so I gave the team plenty of time
what do you need from me how do we set
this up so that you don't need to talk
to me okay we need access to these
things that only you have access to we
need to know this but whatever it was
very little as it turned out and then I
go to Thailand now I am still too much
of a control freak so I really did bring
at least my iPad with me so I could
check in but I didn't respond I didn't
do anything and what magically happened
is everybody just stepped up and they
answered the questions that they would
have asked me themselves because they
were perfectly capable of doing that and
they started taking initiative and
building new things and doing stuff that
I didn't even think to do and I realized
with some
embarrassment that I had been holding
them back that I had by not allowing
them to fail or do things that would be
different than I would I had been
constraining them from becoming leaders
and doing the things they should be
doing and I had built work for myself I
had made them less effective at their
job and I had made my life less good
like how so so that was one of the best
vacations I ever took because it
actually really changed the entire way
that I managed changed the entire way I
viewed leadership and
I love Thailand
amazing just to like building the
systems that then persist after you get
back I mean what a what a liberating
experience that must have been on so
many levels yeah the gift that keeps on
giving no it's something you talk about
a lot and it cannot be underestimated
right so you ask the question right what
would it take for me
to let go right what would it what would
have to be true for you to be willing to
not
get into this it could be some key
metric that you care about that they
have to report it could be that they
have to stay within a certain budget it
could be that they're in reality you're
just making up stories of oh well I just
feel like I need it right let those
things go let people grow and it's
really in my experience it's just been
incredible I now have a team that can
run could literally run itself I get in
and I focus on the key new projects I
focus on the most important things I
think are wrong but I for the most part
I have stepped away from a lot of the
day-to-day and I have watched my team
get better and better better and again
it's part of that mindset right they
make mistakes just like I make mistakes
the question is what do we learn from it
and don't make the same mistake twice
and we've learned a lot along the way
and it's it's been pretty amazing
it's Justin we're coming up on almost
two and a half hours two hours and 17
minutes or 18 minutes
I'll ask just a few more questions and
then we can we can slowly Land This
Plane
so the next question is
one that many long-term listeners will
be familiar with the billboard question
if you could put a quote a question a
phrase a word anything on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get it in
front of millions or billions of people
what might you put on such a billboard
yes I'm excited to get this one I had
anticipated it might come up I've
listened to a lot of the podcasts
so I'm going to use one as a mantra for
myself
which I say to myself every day which is
cultivate comfort with uncertainty and
impermanence
impermanence it sounds a little you know
maybe a little woo-woo to people but in
reality it's so much of what we do we
talked about this a little bit earlier
is because we're afraid that we don't
know what's going to happen we're afraid
we're going to lose something and the
truth is you never know what's going to
happen and you're gonna lose everything
we're all gonna die right and if you can
just be okay in that space of not
knowing right the control freak piece of
it the staying as a lawyer or a safer
path and be okay with the fact that
things are not going to stay the same
all the time then life gets so much
easier and whether it be your creative
path or your relationships or anything
like that has been one of the most
powerful things for me personally so I'd
hope to share that message
that is a perfect place to begin to wrap
up and that is exactly what we're going
to do so Justin people can find think
like a game designer at think like a
game designer.com you mentioned the
slash media for various things they can
find you on Twitter at Justin underscore
Gary any other websites that you would
like to mention or places you'd like to
point people to yeah sure you can come
to stoneblade.com is for my games if you
want to pick up any of my games or join
our Discord there's a link there and we
myself and my team are all there
chatting so you can chat with me on
Twitter and on the Discord I love you
know I'm talking with people that have
design and creativity questions so
always happy to help this has been so
much fun Tim
such a blast people take them up on it I
highly highly encourage you to engage
and thank you Justin for taking so much
time I'm glad we were able to finally
make this happen
really took so many notes so lots to
follow up on personally and to everybody
listening
thank you for tuning in and as always we
will link to everything we discussed and
probably much more in the show notes Tim
dot Blog podcast so you can just search
Justin and I'm sure that this will be
one episode of very few maybe the only
that pops up so you'll be able to find
everything there and until next time
please be just a bit Kinder than is
necessary
both to others and to yourself and with
that Tim Ferriss signing off